Dr Stephen Greer is one of the world's
authorities on the subject of UFOs and
extraterrestrial intelligence he's also
written five books and produced four
feature-length documentaries each listed
in the description with the link he's
currently working on a documentary about
new energy titled the Lost century and
how to regain it to be released in
Spring 2023. I'm joined today generously
by Dan zetterstrom of that UFO podcast
now the link to that podcast will be in
the description and I recommend you
subscribe at around the 20 minutes and
the 40 minute Mark you'll hear an ad for
Trade coffee and Hyundai respectively as
they both sponsor this video thank you
and enjoy if you can see this type in
Spirited Away Spirited Away
you like your anime references
sorry are you there yeah that's all
right so everything okay I I don't know
I somehow it went over to something
called safe driving mode
okay well it must mean that it gets rid
of the video because they don't want you
looking at the video while you're
driving okay we'll be unsafe at the desk
oh yeah I want to give you some some
briefings of my name's Kurt and this is
a theories of everything podcast it's
like a physics term and and I'm
interested in the phenomenon so I
interview people on the phenomena okay
okay so so welcome Dr Greer I'll give
you a great introduction in the edited
version so don't worry go through
accolades and so on welcome Greer sorry
it's Dr Greer and there are thousands of
people watching right now great
hello everyone nice to meet you I'm here
in Washington
okay
so
we'll start off slow and then we'll get
into the meat of it and and just so you
know just let me take this out but just
so you know I I if I feel as if the
question is going on the answer is going
on for a bit too long I mean no
disrespect I may just interject and say
okay so going back to the original
question and so on because you have so
much knowledge and experience and and
you're you're valuable and valuable at
the same time so does that sound fair is
that all right sure no that's fine okay
great great
okay so this question comes from
Santiago who wants to know what's your
workout routine and what type of music
do you listen to
I like alternative rock
uh mostly the alternative uh and uh my
workout routine is about eight hours a
week I do a lot of uh mountain biking
and hiking in the gym I focused on
non-cardio weights so you know I have a
day that I do chess and that I do back
they do legs they do arms each day then
no I I focus on one muscle group a day
well what I mean is you take a day off
like do you have a rest day or each day
you do something yeah yeah I'm usually
one or two days a week I take a break
and then the key thing is you know
nutrition quickly my wife's a good cook
and I like to eat yeah yeah when it
comes to alternative rock just to harp
on that what bands
oh I I there's a new band I like a lot
called Spacey Jane
um I like Awolnation cage the elephants
um some of the older ones Foo Fighters
which of course named their band after
uh UFOs
yeah see this guitar that's all I play
is alternative rock but from the 90s
like Nirvana and our lady piece oh yeah
I love those too yup those are great so
that's why I listened to I just stream
it off at one of the sites and
um I don't actually curate my own list
but I have a friend who does for our
premieres and events he he curates them
for us this question comes from Andy
mcgrillin who says that this podcast
right now what we're doing it's been
anticipated by thousands of people and
you rarely do podcasts so why is it that
you're appearing on this one and you
feel free to compliment theories of
everything as much as you like
well I don't know my people said that it
had a lot of viewers and we're trying to
get some critical information out about
what we're working on coming up in the
next uh eight or nine months and that
you guys could probably help get the
word out and uh inform some of the
public that perhaps I'm not normally
reaching so we thought it'd be a good
idea to communicate with you guys
all right what is it that you're working
on in the next few months eight nine
months well on October 25th of course
we're doing a big event in Santa Monica
and it's a webinar you can join uh but
it's the backbone of a new documentary
feature film uh we anticipate it'll be
more significant than unacknowledged
that has had 760 million people see it
uh this next one is going to be called
The Lost century
so we're crowdfunding it also I mean in
other words all our all our activities
are the people funding that we don't
have a corporate
um or that type of sponsor because we
want to be able to tell the truth and
the whole truth and not have it censored
by somebody who controls the content so
the the Lost century film.com is the
site if you want to help us with that or
you can join us on October 25th the
event itself is sold out in person in
Santa Monica but what we're doing with
that film is to create
um
a movement uh like the disclosure
movement but focus on the technologies
that have been sequestered away that
would get us off oil and gas and coal
and for that matter fake electric cars
like Teslas and solar panels and what
have you that create a huge amount of
pollution and you're plugging your car
into the coal-fired power grid right or
gas-fired power grid say you know 88 not
renewable uh energy from your
electricity grid so there are
Technologies some will call zero point
or Quantum vacuum flux systems
that are
very well established I mean existed but
haven't vanished uh by corrupt interest
both corporate and government so what we
want to do with the Lost Century show
there's a lost Century 100 Years of
these technologies that have been
sequestered and the Earth is in serious
trouble and we're not going to fix it
with just drilling more oil or putting
solar panels around because the solar
panels don't have enough energy density
and that both sides are right and wrong
about some of the policies they're
they're putting forward but what they're
really missing is this third element the
element being that these really Advanced
Technologies some of which are explained
how for example the so-called UFOs don't
have a payload of fuel or nuclear
reactor you know where is the time to
the phenomenon
400 yeah I always wish when I'm up here
in DC and if I'm having a meeting with
some people uh critically and you know
folks who are supposedly manage the
intelligence Community here in
Washington you know I'll point to that
Tic Tac that everyone made such much and
noise about and I said that's an
alternative energy and propulsion device
just think of it that way you know don't
make this any more esoteric and in that
case it almost certainly was from the
Lockheed Skunk Works in other words it
was not quote unquote an even on board
or extraterrestrial
so I think this is gets into the whole
discussion of where have our tax dollars
gone what do we have in classified
projects
um what part of that can be disclosed so
that we could move off of oil and gas
and coal and uh and really create a new
civilization based on technologies that
Nikola Tesla the real Tesla uh and
others began to discover back in the
late 1800s and early 1900s so we have a
hundred years where we've lost
um social and I think spiritual
Evolution with it and we've trapped the
planet environmentally on a downward
spiral to nearly an extinction level
event that's coming out quickly and the
other problem is that half the world's
population is an unbelievable poverty
you know in the west we're so
narcissistic we think oh well we have
hundreds of years of oil and gas here in
you know North America or wherever or
the Middle East uh which is probably
true
but the biosphere can't withstand
hundreds of years more and that doesn't
count about half the world's population
doesn't have electricity uh or a way of
life like we do I mean three billion
people don't have any way to cook their
their meals uh they're they're
scrounging and tearing down old growth
rainforests or desert plants to cook and
make charcoal that's three billion The
Economist just came out with that number
a few months ago so if we're really
going to live as a planet that lives can
be at all just which means it can be
peaceful and get to what some people
call a level one civilization we're
going to have to really quickly bring
these sciences and Technologies out so
that's the next big thrust course is
that the it's in the core message of the
disclosure project but this entire
documentary film be focused on that and
then we're going to also describe how
these technologies have vanished and
what we need to change to get them out
to the public coffee helps me work it
helps me fast from carbs it's become one
of the best parts of my day consistently
that's why I'm delighted that we're
collaborating with Trade coffee they
partner with top independent Roasters to
Freshly roast and send the finest coffee
in the country directly to your home on
your preferred schedule this matters to
me as I work from home their team of
experts do all the work testing hundreds
of disparate coffees to land on a final
curated collection of 450 exceptional
coffees I chose these three and the team
at Trade coffee worked to create a
special lineup for theories of
everything for the tow audience based on
some questions they asked me such as how
much caffeine do I enjoy and what's the
bitterness ratio Etc you can get that
line up or if that's not let's say your
cup of coffee then you can take your own
quiz on their website to find a set that
matches your specific profile if you'd
like to support small businesses and
Brew the best cup of coffee you've ever
made at home then it's time to try Trade
coffee right now trade is offering toe
listeners a total of thirty dollars off
your subscription plus free shipping at
drinktrade.com everything that's
drinktrade.com everything for thirty
dollars off your subscription to the
best coffees in the country
drinktray.com everything interesting
okay about the technologies that vanish
just so you know I get people who claim
at least claim that they were inspired
by UFOs or they have tapped in just on
their own to the same
physics that they're operating by and
they have some technology and they want
to show me but I have this policy of I'm
sorry if you can't come public with it
like show everyone then don't show it to
me because I don't want to have any
information that I can't talk about so
that's just my own policy I don't like
to have to sign an NDA or be in
possession of anything that I can't talk
about and what they tell me is Kurt as
soon as I go forward with this I will
people have died from this the
government has silenced people and I'm
worried for my health my safety or I've
been contacted by the government
officials who are trying to silence me
so in other words those are some fears
that people have now I'm curious do you
have those fears and how warranted are
they
they're very warranted and we can prove
that this has happened I mean I've been
personally involved in teams that have
had the result of a wet Works group kill
its principal people what works is cie
term for wet from blood being killed and
you know I've had myself on the watch
group list more than once which is the
kill list but I think that what how do
you know that sorry I don't mean to
interrupt I just thoughts occur to me so
how was it disclosed to you that well
you remember I'm starting in 93 I
briefed people like the director of the
CIA and I have a network of people in
clandestine services and elsewhere who
uh
who are friendly to what we're doing
they want to stick their necks out too
far because they don't end up like Bill
Colby the CI director who is helping us
back in the 90s bring one of these
Technologies out and they found him
floating down here south of DC in the in
the river
um he was wet work his best friend was a
colonel who was on our team and
confirmed that that was a kill but made
to look like an accident so these guys
are not without Foundation what they're
they're huge mistake and this is a big
part of this film and you're going to
hear about this if you join our podcast
on October uh 25th
there is a strategy to avoid that but
everyone keeps making the same mistakes
and as Einstein said with you know
definition of insanity is doing the
thing same thing over and over expecting
a different result so what we've done is
analyzed 120 years or so of these sort
of Technologies how they've come and
then how they vanished what are the
mistakes that are consistently made and
you named it you hit the nail on the
head they're trying to keep it secret
now you know what I tell people is that
if you have something like that contact
me yesterday
um immediately and that you have to be
prepared to open source it now what does
open source mean it's like GitHub the
software company it means that you
release all of it without any holdback
to the public but massively so what I
would do is have a massive
press conference around it but it would
have been released
the entire plants how it operates
nothing held back forget patenting this
stuff it's going to get seized
um to a national security order NSO and
so what you have to do is is say okay
the the whole system is set up
to intercept these the big one of the
biggest ones are financial and legal
traps uh that are out there because
people taking quote investors the other
is that you'll be offered a lot of money
be black shelved I mean if it's enough
information and knowledge they'll
they'll try to buy it off and and put it
on a shelf where nobody sees it
that we know specific cases where that's
happened well that person is Rich the
inventor and his team but you know the
world's dying right right so now there
is another way to do this but it's very
against what most venture capital and
financial and legal and business people
would say and that is you take all the
details of that invention
and you release it open source and
without any holdbacks no patent for the
good of humanity yes but it would also
be for the good of the person I'll get
to this in a minute this is very
counterintuitive and this is where you
have to you can have a a 100 million
dollars in an operational device but if
you don't strategically understand what
you're up against you're up against 800
trillion 900 trillion dollar
uh cartels of energy utilities oil gas
coal all of this uh the petrodollar
system you're not going to take that on
even if someone gives you a billion
dollars if you don't have the right
strategy so what I explain to people is
that what I what I discovered from
working with a number of these groups
beginning with Bruce De Palma in 1991
and subsequently the tuari device and
many others and the Stan Meyer family
that had the car running on water those
were real systems but they all made the
same mistake they kept the the
technology Secret in a small group of
people so I recommend you have to do
something called detargeting how do you
detarget yourself or you do what I've
done you get it out there you put it out
there and uh that's what I do with the
disclosure project you don't sit on this
sort of thing because if nobody knows
here's a tree that fell in the woods
that nobody ever heard right so if you
don't want to be the tree that falls in
the woods which means another dead body
or a confiscated technology you push it
out here's one of the problems if you're
in a lab at Lawrence Berkeley labs like
a man I know who discovered one of these
a physicist
and nobody knows who you are you don't
have the means to get a billion two
billion people aware of it what my group
has developed or groups of influencers
and celebrities and others that we would
be able to get that out to people and
you know at least a billion to two
billion people in a couple of weeks in a
fortnight so what that means is that you
squeeze the toothpaste out of the tube
so fast and so hard these fascists can't
put it back in
sure how do you get it out to let's say
a billion people how do you do that what
is that like a newsletter or a video
about like this is popular this is a few
thousand but no for example you know
there there are people who are very very
supportive of what what I'm working on
like uh Demi Lovato and Ariana Grande
and other celebrities and I you know we
say hey drop this link to your 150
million followers and the link will go
straight to the plan so that everybody
could build one of these who's skilled
in the heart of electrical engineering
so you have to get it out why is that
because the group that wants to the
these sort of Nefarious covert groups
who've been keeping these technology
secret they're counting on them
remaining obscure and your obscurity is
your Achilles heel if you don't have a
billion or two billion people who know
about it and you're not going to get
cooperation from the mainstream media
because the mainstream media is corrupt
and we'll ban it it will absolutely ban
the story on it now of course you know
we say well the mainstream media are
ostensibly pro-environmental not on this
I'll tell you a very funny story a
briefing 120 world leaders and on an
island and you're the Great Barrier Reef
uh back about nine years ago and the
most hostile person when I discussed
this I was on a panel with the head of
British Petroleum and a whole bunch of
other people the Minister of Defense of
Australia was there and a bunch of other
world leaders but the most hostile
person out of that 120 person crowd was
the head of Greenpeace
because it would be it sounds like a
dangerous message remember I'm just a
naive foolish person so I don't know so
if this is not dangerous but it sounds
like this is extremely dangerous so how
is it that you've protected yourself
other than making yourself known to many
people and is that the same strategy Bob
Lazar tried to use
well yes but remember he was a young man
who was only there a few weeks and saw
very little
um information about this
I have over 1100 well over a thousand
people like him but who have been
involved in much more critical
information so what what I've had to do
is not is have support from inside the
system
and So speaking very bluntly back in the
90s when a number of us were targeted
with an electromagnetic weapon where we
were all dropping dead of various
cancers I mean as you know I had
metastatic malignant melanoma
Congressman we were working with who was
digging in the Roswell
had a strange cancer that killed him in
six months and my right hand assistant
was killed and Bill Colby was killed and
I'd had a man come to me every year and
say hey do you want protection
and I'm you know I'm a civilian never
been the government I'm a medical trauma
doctor emergency doctor I said no no but
when this happened I said make it so so
there's a group that protects us
um that have significant countermeasures
in in their capabilities that keep it at
a sort of a you should be called a
Mexican standoff you know we're
basically you know we're not being
bothered and that's true of anyone who
comes into our group because it extends
the people working with me
um and it's work it's held for 20 that
was put in place in 98 so it's held for
24 years
is this a is this a private group or is
it easy with the US government no they
said well
okay you have to understand first of all
we have to Define terms there's two
governments there's the U.S government
of the Constitution and the people and
then there's a secret government as
Senator inui said uh in that famous talk
when he said there is a secret
government with its own Air Force its
own Navy it's some funding mechanism
that's above the wall and free from the
law so
so this gets into some shadowy stuff
right so but there are people on both
ends of those governmental spectrum that
are very very supportive so like right
now I'm in Washington because I'm taking
meetings with people who are military
officials assigned to the White House
and the People Who oversee the black
budget of the United States and the
Congress that I'm providing the
information to the actionable
intelligence so that they can penetrate
these programs
that's very dangerous I mean it's
extremely but that's happening right now
I mean that's what's what we're working
on right now
um because the Congress passed a law now
those guys when they get when I get them
read in I suppose it's called or briefed
on all this and I onboard them
with all the information we have because
I'll give them information like here's
the project code names here's where
they're located here's the gate here's
the section of this base where there's
an underground facility where an
extraterrestrial vehicle is being
studied Etc and so on
and because of that because they have
the ability to kick doors in
uh they they've hit they've hit Pay Dirt
in the last six months it's a big
announcement actually but it's not being
reported yet meet mainstream media and
hopefully my name stays out of it um but
nevertheless or groups of people who are
very supportive of what we're trying to
do and is taken very seriously and one
part of that group are people who can
protect and they do protect
so and then there's some other ways I
think things that are not quite seen
that are protected but anyway we we're
we're you know I never would I would
never be so arrogant to say that you
know I'm sort of an Untouchable person I
think it's what we're doing is dangerous
but I accepted the dangers of this back
in
92 and 93
you know it was in May of 1992 30 years
ago that the head of Army intelligence
General uh stubblebine
uh Bert Albert stubblemine the third is
what he went by offered me two billion
dollars to not talk about this or pursue
this
um I told him you know I'm not for sale
and then he went to my wife tried to
convince my wife and that was a big
mistake on his part because no one does
that
um but that was 30 years ago so I mean
the corrupt the capability to corrupt
people here
um is very high who offered that to you
the 2 billion
the head open uh the general stubble
mind he had been head Army intelligence
and special forces and he was a member
of this Elite group and the intelligence
group some call it magic I have a a
national reconnaissance Office document
that has magic on it m a j i c it stands
for the majority intelligence committee
that deals with the UFO and
extraterrestrial issue and it's related
subjects including macroeconomic issues
and these Technologies now remember
these technologies that we're going to
be exposing in the Lost century and by
the way there are four of them we would
like to feature more that we've that are
operational right now as you and I are
speaking
but they are tied up in a strategic plan
by the inventor and their investors
that means it'll never see the day of
light they're they're either already
dead men walking or they are so encumber
legally and financially that the public
will never get the benefit of them the
only reason I'm going to expose them uh
in this documentary
that we're working on uh so stay tuned
uh please help us do this uh we're is
that I think the public needs to know
that over the last hundred years there
have been thousands of these
breakthroughs and people say how can
that be I suppose the walls of the
universe are Universal if you're a
physicist or a scientist like we are you
know that the laws of the universe are
Universal so what does that mean it
means that whatever can be discovered on
another star systems you know from
another star system can be discovered by
people on this planet
and even you know a lot of people look
at this sort of anti-gravity which is a
bad term but gravity control is the
proper term
um that is tied into the whole Zero
Point Energy uh aspect that began to be
experimentally observed by t-towns and
brown uh and others back in the 1920s
were very very high frequency
electromagnetic signals at voltages in
the millions of volts but at low power
would cause objects to look like they're
levitating and that was done in the 20s
so these are well documented
uh what most people don't know is that
October 1954 is when these clandestine
projects within the U.S government
mastered gravity control quote unquote
I'm quoting from like
uh redacted uh top secret document but
my people here in Washington one of whom
was the chief scientist at the Naval
Research Labs who is of course the one
that it's the biggest Department of
Defense lab and Thomas Edison started it
he uh Richard fosh who's now passed away
he went into the Vault where a lot of
these documents are kept and saw the
document that stated Point Blank that we
mastered gravity control in 1954. this
brings up a big problem in the UFO
community
and also with the Congressional hearings
that are happening here people look at
those objects and they think that if
it's not a jet fighter or a rocket
because those are all like 30s 40s era
Technologies it has to be quote-unquote
extraterrestrial or alien I'm going
that's nonsense most of what these
objects are that people see are from my
my uncle worked for Northrop Grumman his
whole career and I worked on the lunar
module landed on the moon with no
Armstrong in it or and so Northrop
Grumman and Lockheed Martin and Booz
Allen Hamilton and EG and G and we know
who the contractors are and where
there's facilities are many of these
objects that people see of various
shapes are man-made now that's a bigger
secret than the ET story why because if
it were to get out
now we've had those sort of Technology
since 1954.
68 years and he didn't need to have
Rockets blowing up and killing space
shuttle astronauts uh and the Apollo
accidents that killed Apollo Astronauts
and jet fuel that when a plane crashes
goes into a ball of Fire
and the damage to the environment and
half the world in poverty since the 50s
this would be a thousand times more
scandalous than Watergate so they want
the UFO subculture and the media that's
begun to jump on this bandwagon to say
oh this is a uh you know we don't know
what this is well we do know what it is
you know this is one of the big problems
there's this big Gulf between what's
known in covert programs and what say
the the people on the Senate
intelligence committee or armed services
committee or these other oversight
committees in the Congress or for that
matter the president and the National
Security Council everyone thinks that
those folks have an all-access passed
they do not and this is a very hard
lesson I learned in 1993 when I was
asked to fly up here from my hospital in
North Carolina where I was working as an
emergency doctor in briefed the sitting
director of the CIA and a bunch of other
officials eventually is that they did
not have access to those projects which
I found to be frankly not credible I did
not believe it I thought this is the
biggest bunch of horseshit excuse my
language there's no way that you're the
director of the CIA or the president and
you're being blocked access to these
projects that that my uncle and other
people had had knowledge of and that I
had collected a huge
portfolio of evidence
but it is the case and so I think the
public when they talk about the
government keeping the secret they're
making a very big fundamental mistake in
that
primary statement
because they're assuming that the
government will We the People knows
anything about most of this now there
are a few of them that do and they are
corrupt politicians on the payroll of
this cabal of sociopaths and Nazis but
um but basically most of them have no
idea and when I meet with them they're
genuinely astonished that this could be
true and they don't know about it
because it might be a key member of the
Senate intelligence committee or a key
member of some other oversight committee
or like I said you know people in the
Pentagon that I have briefed like the
head of the uh defense intelligence
agency that I briefed him and and this
is a guy by the way General Hughes you
know if you know Military Intelligence
that's the top of the pecking order the
the the the director of the defense
intelligence agency is the top of all
military intelligence in the United
States
and he had been totally blocked and
ridiculed for even asking about the
subject but he knew nothing about it you
just mentioned um
yeah uh Patrick Hughes and we have a
question about him so I thought it would
be a good time to jump in uh it's kind
of an empty when I read it out to you uh
from Joe magia in 1998 uh you and your
former see Sati military advisor
Commander will Miller uh you briefed us
it had the DIA uh Patrick Hughes the
champion you just mentioned who had
asked for the briefing to be expedited
uh you said that uh Patrick hughes's dad
uh committed suicide because nobody in
the government would take this seriously
uh is it possible is Dad learned
something unsettling about the phenomena
that led to his suicide can you expand
on the Hughes family in their
relationship with the phenomena and I
wanted to ask if Hughes was present for
your briefing of Admiral Wilson in April
of 1997 with Miller in the attendance
no those were separate they were set up
separately and Admiral Wilson
um with in both all these cases and I'm
still doing this what I what we do is we
provide like a presidential briefing
document that I've handed off teach
president since uh Clinton uh those are
provided
um to them in advance so there are
documents and information and
assessments and cases
and based on that in the case of Admiral
Wilson this is not well understood and
you know the Eric Davis memo that came
out where everyone was all this big
kerfuffle I don't know why there was a
big profile I disclosed this meeting
what happened at it 20 years prior but
somehow everyone must have thought that
somehow what I was saying could not
possibly be true until this this Dr
Davis released this transcript of his
interview with that Wilson years later
but uh Admiral Wilson was wanting to be
read in on this and he made inquiries
now he did
in fact hit a couple of key points based
on some documentation we had given him
and but the response he got back was uh
you know basically the way he told it
was that the uh one office that he got
hold of and contractor because most of
the really important work is wfo worked
for other contractors like a Lockheed or
some Corporation I mean U.S government
doesn't make anything you know they
contract so he uh was told
you know he said look I'm Admiral Wilson
I'm head of an Intel I'm J2 head of
intelligence attorneys they say yes sir
we know who you are
but he go and they go but oh you don't
have a need to know
he says how can I not have a need to
know if I'm the head of intelligence for
the joint Jesus staff they said sir we
will not discuss this with you and they
cut the line
so he continued to dig into it but
eventually he got threatened uh with the
motion and other threats and by demotion
I mean they were going to take a star
off his lapel and all this so he was
like but when we had the meeting I
brought um there was an astronaut back
in the day Edgar Mitchell it was Apollo
astronaut that I was mentoring and
sharing this information with so I
brought him to the meeting
along with some other folks and the
Admiral was shaken but you know it was
supposed to be a 45 minute stand-up
briefing where I stand up and go through
you know all this and the assessment and
the risk assessment The Matrix of a risk
of this being kept secret and being
mismanaged this way all that kind of
thing and what it ended up going on for
like three hours two or three hours it
only ended because it had to go up to a
New York uh City interview TV interview
but um the Admiral you know it was kind
of poignant and sad at the end of it I
said look we really need your help to
get this under control this is an
existential threat to the world and to
the United States national security the
way this is being managed she says yes
it is he says but the best thing I have
it sounds kind of comical is a B2
stealth bomber that I know about and I
now know there's a group that have
craft man-made they can do circles
around my B2 stealth and he says it's
Point set match I mean an outgun
and he says besides which I couldn't
start an investigation on this without
the authorization of the sect F
Secretary of Defense and the president
he I said well that won't be forthcoming
because both of them have been waived
off and they are not going to push on
this for fear of well as Bill Clinton's
friend told me if we were being ended up
by Jack Kennedy literally so so he says
well then I'm very happy to have this
information but there's nothing I can do
now that you can Replay that little back
and forth that I summarize in two or
three minutes many many times here in
Washington and London in Canada
Australia other places I've been to most
of the five eyes countries except New
Zealand discussing this with officials
but the the problem is you know if they
don't have authorization from their
prime minister or president to do the
extraordinary things you'd have to do to
get this under control they're kind of
stuck now the good news is that Congress
has passed a law mandate that this be
investigated and that's now enshrined in
the law so there's a window open that
we're moving through now in the case of
General Hughes General Hughes was um I
don't I didn't know his family look I
mean My People set this up I get ushered
in you're at the Pentagon
um but it was very poignant because what
he did the very first thing he did he
had you know we're in the conference
room for the for the general
for the defense intelligence agency uh
office and he goes over to a bookshelf
and grabs this little cheesy E.T alien
looking doll like you would get at a
store
uh you know at Walgreens or something
and uh he looked he because this is all
I've gotten for my inquiries through the
chain of command
and I told him I said well I have met
with uh people in associated with the
DIA who know about this those are one of
my disclosure project Witnesses he says
well why won't they tell me I said
because they don't want you to know
I say your rank has nothing to do with
it I said you're in the same camp as
some of the presidents and Senators I've
met with and and others see and this is
the upside down world of a Beyond black
I mean there are people I know who
manage unacknowledged projects and black
projects but this is in its own category
and so you know this guy was really not
happy about it and the reason this issue
came up uh about his dad is that and I
don't know the circumstances of it but
he just his first question to me which
was a little disturbing and unnerving
was Dr Greer we don't under we don't
know why you haven't committed suicide
yet
knowing what you okay so that is how
that whole thing came up and I didn't
dwell on it I just said well I have a
different spiritual View and I sort of
have a way of the Stress Management what
do you mean by that what do you mean by
that
he meant that the gravity of knowing
this and doing this most people when
they see what you're up against many
people have committed suicide
it's you know I call it disclosure PTSD
it's a special kind of uh stressor you
know
um you know I don't know if you guys
anyone listening imagine being a
30-some-year-old doctor
being flown up the brief the sitting
director of the CIA and he's shaken to
his core because he and the president
can't find out information
um on an issue that is of critical
National Security importance that's when
you realize the entire system is upside
down
that also has been corrupted you know
the best way to characterize the
organization keeping all this secret
including the technologies that we need
to bring out very quickly the at least
the energy ones if not the ones that fly
the ones that fly need to come out later
because they could be missile Delivery
Systems but the ones that can sit in
your house like your heat pump and run
your house with no uh no power bill and
no pollution or could it be in a a test
the car get rid of the 900 pounds of
lithium ion batteries that catch fire
and are very polluting when you mine
them and create them and you would have
an electromagnetic motor 300 horsepower
motor like Floyd Suite had and he had a
little cigarette path size Quantum uh
flux uh device that would run that 300
horsepower engine but of course when he
started to move that out he got killed
he was assassinated
um and he's going to be we're going to
feature that one of the people who
worked with him we've interviewed he's
still living and uh he's up there in
some years and you're gonna you're gonna
hear about this but but that sort of
thing is very stressful and I think the
the people who I've met with in
Washington who got pretty close to this
they usually back off the edge of the
cliff when they realize that we took in
Senator gillibrand and people like Marco
Rubio the people that are really pushing
this uh like Matt Gallagher yeah oh yeah
but they're yes and there are there's a
a growing number the problem is
um they're not they're not allowed to
know or read be read in through channels
uh what's actually going on I mean
they're still asking questions like you
know geez are these from China or are
these what are they you know um so let
me interject if you don't mind is that
all right yeah no no go ahead yeah so I
know what people are thinking uh because
people are constantly thinking so what's
where's the evidence for so-and-so
because there's many many claims here
and obviously you can't give evidence
for each one because it would just be a
three-day event I wouldn't mind a
three-day event that's actually pretty
cool like a three-day podcast but either
way so where is the evidence for hmm I
don't have a specific claim in mind so
when certain ones come up I may
interject and be like okay what evidence
is there for this that's accessible to
other people because of course we can
say so-and-so told me and and I'm sure
you wouldn't accept that as evidence and
and there is such a thing as
disinformation it was hidden it's in
plain sight of course nobody reads I
mean the disclosure book is 500 and some
pages of whistleblower top secret
transcripts and and government documents
but and it's there anyone who wants to
get it can get it just go get it would
people be able to find your you you
mentioned that you do have a kind of a
presidential brief impact are people
able to view that for example
not everything in there it's something
that I would want to put out because it
has names and people here's what here's
something that you have to understand
out of the 1100 or so guys who come to
me and some women who worked in these
areas only less than 10 percent of them
have been willing to be exposed publicly
in other words
um there's a man I'm working with right
now who is at the Nellis range on a
retrieval team to retrieve both man-made
UFOs became disabled and uh
extraterrestrial ones and but he has had
so many threats he does not want to be
known in the public but I will give his
information to these key Black Project
investigators here in Washington but and
he he's happy with that so you could
release a document but redact those
names yeah so if you look at the last
like in April I did a three-day
workshop and we had a whole hour hour
and a half where I presented his
evidence in his case but and the details
there was nothing withheld except the
man's name
um now that's because one of the things
if you want people to come to you with
very sensitive information that for
which they've been threatened with being
killed
um if if they were to be known publicly
talking about it then you better keep
their uh their identities confidential
which I do yeah I mean and any doctor is
trained to do that people come to
doctors until
um I have a friend who's a medical
doctor up in Dayton Ohio at
Wright-Patterson Air Force Base and and
he's had many people who work there on
the ET materiel and other Technologies
spin-off Technologies but you know he
would never speak of those people's
names publicly because it was done
within the the sanctity of the
doctor-patient relationship
um and he would not violate that
although he will give me that
information
only because I'm a fellow physician and
he knows I'm going to convey it to
people who can actually do something
about it
um and you know who are now authorized
by law mandated by law by the way to do
this now you know you have to make a
distinction between what I'm talking
about right now and the dog and pony
show at the Pentagon office and the
Congressional office and I'll let you
see in Politico and the New York Times
that's none of that's relevant to what
I'm discussing that this is happening
with with people who actually have the
ability to do something uh most of these
things it's like Project Blue Book was
sort of a PR front store operation to
satisfy members of Congress and and the
public the real actions were going on
elsewhere and this is
this is unfortunate I mean I had my own
feeling is that all of it all to be very
transparent happening very quickly but
you know the United States government
doesn't operate that way nor does any
other government
um and but I do think that you know
there's great progress right now being
made I mean more in the 32 years I've
been doing this it's the biggest
breakthroughs that I have seen in 32
years and so there's a lot of potential
let's just say there's a lot of
potential
have you ever thought about your car
personality so what's your Vibe classic
fully gas powered or are you more like
the many worlds interpretation where you
want the Best of Both Worlds that is
driving battery powered while keeping
gas for Reserve just in case or are you
more inclined to choose a convenient
hybrid ride whichever your Vibe there's
a Tucson Hyundai to match and a
Powertrain to get you there Hyundai's
2023 Tucson lineup pairs the tech you
want with sleek and stylish designs they
paid attention to all the details the
seat the dash the available panoramic
roof you name it Hyundai thought of it
all while making sure that each trim has
enough room for grocery runs Festival
nights and tailgates okay Hyundai when
it comes to your journey Hyundai is
there for every mile visit
hyundaiusa.com to learn more about the
2023 Hyundai Tucson the 2023 Tucson
hybrid is only sold in California
Colorado Connecticut Maine Maryland New
Jersey New York Oregon Rhode Island and
Vermont want what I like especially
about the first part of this when you
came on about the open sourceness I am
I'm not an academic but I'm trained as
an academic so I like open source and
then the question about the briefing so
why won't you release it well there's
names okay that's cool and then you have
released it to some of the people who
are at some live event now is there a
reason that it's exclusive to people at
a live event because I'm sure then oh no
it's up on our YouTube channel now
remember our YouTube channel has like
500 videos some of which are two to four
hours long and it's Dr Stephen Greer
it's whatever it is like in PDF form I
mean like PowerPoint presentation or
however it is that you deliver yes well
that's those are going to be create
that's what we're creating so this huge
archive that we're collecting that we're
putting together for the US government
White House National Security Council
Congress that we're going to have a
version of it when we get it done
hopefully in the next uh 10 months that
would be accessible by the public
but you know again you have to
understand we're not a Rich Podcast like
you we're of all volunteers and we don't
have an office or staff now I am hiring
away from an aerospace company I'm not a
Rich Podcast just so you know oh I
thought same oh well you know when I was
on Joe Rogan you know those kind of
people I was never offered two billion
oh you weren't given 100 million dollars
by Spotify then you know if you would
take my interview out of the lineup you
know that's what Joe Rogan did he took
he took my interview out of the lineup
so it could get the 100 million dollars
from my Spotify oh yeah how do you think
deals like that are made there's a quid
pro quo let's take out anything that's
really inflammatory anyway
um you say how cynical I haven't got the
media uh big media so in any rate well
okay firstly like I recommend you I'm
happy that you're on and I appreciate
that you're willing to come in here and
answer some questions that again like it
sounds answering but just a fatuous
person so when I say what's evidence for
so-and-so I mean no disrespect it's just
my uh
it is you want but again we put these
together in so many formats where
there's video books but most people you
know they can only stand reading the
headlines so people want to drill down
in It Go drill down on them I have five
books out
um there are you know like I said a
thousand hours or more of of really
densely packed information and
presentations with those PowerPoints on
the YouTube channel great great I
appreciate that you're not offended by
it I I appreciate that at all I mean
because there'll be more questions like
that coming yeah there'll be anyone like
that should uh you know I mean but what
I say is say you know go do it you know
I can't spoon feed it to you if you're
not willing to read of course nobody
it's Politically Incorrect to read or do
math as you know
um
okay so about the the documentary that's
coming up the Lost century and how to
regain it the you said there's a plan
for there to be a
push of something open source with
regard to energy how's that coming does
that come along with the website like
how does that work does that come a week
before a week after no let me be clear
we don't have any technology we don't
have an inventor or a Technology Group
that's willing to do that because
they're like you know the movie uh Lord
of the Rings my precious my precious
Gollum with his ring
ironically some of them are to our Royal
ranks uh those folks do not want to lose
control of it and ownership of it by
open sourcing it but they don't
understand if they would open source it
and connect to a big group uh strategic
group like we've created that could get
the word out to a billion people I mean
you know my first here's how how sort of
out of the box I think about stuff like
this everybody wants to go through a
normal Venture Capital rounds of funding
which
is ridiculous because if you had a
company that had a market cap of what
Tesla Motors does of a trillion dollars
it's not enough it's too little and it's
too late the only way we're going to fix
this existential crisis on the planet is
that these Technologies are released
open source and there are a thousand
companies that are developing it now the
person who developed it originally it's
like if you invented the first xerox
machine there's going to be a huge
inflow of support but the other thing
the reason that thinking is so not
correct
is that there's 1.5 billion cars on the
road that have to be retrofitted and
converted they're two and a half billion
homes well what general electorate
General Motors Amazon and apple
altogether could not do that in 20 years
and it has to be done in 20 years so
this is like a I call like a global
Marshall Plan like the plan that we had
to rescue Europe after World War II
where we put together you know the
funding and the strategy to resurrect
From the Ashes Western Europe well this
is a global plan that has to happen it
has to happen within 20 25 years and to
do it you need a huge amount of
involvement it can't be something where
you're sitting on it secretively
ironically the secretiveness about this
is what gets people killed number one
because
they're targeting themselves so like
let's say you uh Kurt have one of these
devices and you have a team of 12
investors and physicists and
electromagnetic Engineers it'd be so
easy to rub you out and you'd vanish and
who the hell would ever know about
this is what happened to the team that
got the Stan Meyer archive you know
because he Stan Meyer not only had a car
that was running on water it was
actually running on zero point we can
get to that in a moment if you want to
hear the physics of it
um and the uh that he also had a device
that had a national security order on it
that we knew about had photographs of it
and it was like a toroid and it was
putting out enormous amounts of energy
way more than you had to supply to it
because it was also accessing this um
very high voltage electromagnetic charge
system that Taps into and creates sort
of a space-time cavitation from the zero
point and this is what they're doing
so that ended up being can you talk more
about the physics too
you said you could talk about the
physics
well yeah but I mean it's if you're if
you're talking to a general audience
who's gonna no one's going to care about
pointing vectors and the what Maxwell
equations were altered and all that
stuff
um but what I'm trying to get to is that
they
we were trying to get it but they had a
big funder that outbid us for the Stan
Meyer Warehouse
including this toroid
and that was the real action by the way
not the car
well a couple years later you know had
huge amount of funding it was up in
Michigan I finally get a call from Lord
somebody I won't say his name uh in the
British Isles who had been the Thunder
and he was in a panic he says look
they're on the run for their lives
they've got all this stuff operational
now remember the day that it slipped
into that world where they were going to
try to monetize it secretively I said
these are all Dead Men Walking I said
that you know the way they're doing this
is guaranteed to fail it is guaranteed
to fail
but now finally this Lord so-and-so
calls me up I don't he got my number
somehow and he's in a panic and I'm here
in Washington I said let me write a
strategic overview
of what needs to happen within 24 to 48
hours
because they were saying oh we're going
to go to an eco-friendly country I said
you'd have to go to an eco-friendly star
system there's nowhere on this planet
where this these the henchmen who want
to keep this secret won't get you find
you it's just not going to happen
um they don't rep they don't recognize
any geopolitical country boundaries for
their operations tactically so I said
look you do this so it was exactly what
we're talking about you open source it
immediately you then hand off all that
information to us and I will get
you know 20 of the top celebrities
working on this to announce it to all
their fans and get all the fan girls and
Fanboys of people like from Justin
Bieber to whoever you know Godsmack to
Justice Beaver yeah they're all really
into it so um so what what I tell people
is that why because I said because
you're going to get blocked at the media
level which is controlled by corporate
there are shills for big corporate
interests you're gonna get blocked by uh
the tech companies but what they cannot
block are these big influencers who have
100 200 million followers on Instagram
or wherever and those people have one of
these devices running their house how
are you going to stop if
one of these A-list celebrities or 20 or
30 of them have their cars and their
house running no it you know people say
what's a PR style I said no it's not
it's a way to get around the Embargo of
this information through the corrupt
media so I said but look this is what
this is what you got to do you got to do
it very quickly now the next thing I
know they they had decided they were
going to still keep it secret they
wanted to be you know like Gollum and
Gauntlet with the Lord of the Rings and
hold on to their precious might they
were to my knowledge all but one of them
were killed they all vanished okay so
let's talk about the physics of the
precious man I was involved in that very
very specifically it's very sad
so the physics aspect you mentioned that
people may not people just so you know
come to this podcast in particular for
the technicalities of physics that's
what we're our main right is physics
okay so you're welcome more than welcome
to speak as advanced as you like well
one one thing to look at is the is the
resource that has been done
um by people like Ken shoulders who who
since have passed away who had his
charge cluster arrays and basically what
those were were little tiny ball
lightning
and it's now been discovered that these
little electrostatic ball lightning type
packets when they discharge they're
actually perturbing or stimulating this
this Quantum flux zero point field of
energy and it causes a cavitation in
space-time that causes an enormous uh
force of forward moving force that can
be put against the pits and or turn a
rotor for a generator or what have you
most scientists over the last hundred
years didn't know how that was happening
it got imaged uh not too long ago very
very well by a scientist a physicist in
Tokyo I believe it's University of Tokyo
I forget his the gentleman's name where
they were able to image that this is
what was going on
now that's true of whether it was Stan
Meyer with his electrostatic system to
create hydrogen and oxygen gas
the hydrogen and oxygen gas from
dissociating you have to you know beat
the Faraday constant you know the amount
of electrical engine it has to go into
from an electrolyzer to separate the
bond of hydrogen and oxygen which is
what H2O water is in this case the even
the amount of hydrogen and oxygen gas
wouldn't explain how far that car would
run because if you calculate the energy
of what's in that hydrogen and oxygen
gas so what it was really doing and this
is because it was doing it on demand it
was actually accessing this excess
energy let's call it from this Baseline
Quantum flux field or Zero Point Energy
field through these high voltage uh
circuits now I don't think Stan Meyer
understood the physics so because that's
just now getting increasingly elaborated
a very good source for this is Maury
King's book that talks about water uh
the the source of new energy and the
zero point
um it's a bit dense he's an engineer and
it's a but if you're a physicist I'd
recommend you take a look at that book
Maury King we just interviewed him about
this so there are many ways to do it
it's basically people have done it with
different media you can do it through an
electromagnetic crystalline substance
you can do it through water you can do
it this through the circuitry of
electrically charged steel like the
Holcomb device down in Florida and you
can also do it through solid-state
oscillator resonance where you're having
the same effect
uh in in these and the key thing is here
vhv very high voltage systems at certain
frequencies and the sort of little what
you look at when you look at it
microscopically these tiny ball
lightning type phenomenon that create
this sort of cavitation and space time
how high of a voltage are we talking
about
Millions
I mean it depends on what you're doing I
mean votes yeah but at very low low Uh
current so the power is very low so you
might put 100 watts into a system and
get you know a kilowatt out or five
kilowatts out ultimately you know I just
was at a place out in the desert of
Arizona where we witnessed this is going
to be we're going to show this on our
our pod not podcast our webinar on
October 25th
this device that had I think it was four
magnesium alloy plates and this
particular device was more like an
original Tesla sort of a miniaturized
version of warden cliff where this guy
for after 40 Years of trying to do this
something that's a little bit bigger
than a shoe box
and at the startup Powers three volt
battery which you could take out and
it's actually pulling the magnetic flux
and the What's called the negative
energy that's around us uh and it's it
was when we were there a few weeks ago
it was had been running for over two
years this negative energy around us
well he calls it negative energy I think
it's what I think a lot of these terms
are fungible because they're still being
defined I think what he calls negative
energy is actually an aspect of the the
zero point the quantum flux field
um so with you know without getting too
much further into those weeds what the
strange thing about his device it has to
be tuned to the magnetic field and of of
the earth exactly where it is because
it's actually feeding off the flow of
energy from the Sun to the Earth and the
magnetosphere it's very interesting very
it's very tesla-like but instead of it
being this gigantic thing it's like this
big I mean you know so we're there and I
we test it there are no wires going into
it it's putting out
um it was putting out we've got it
around five kilowatts
and no energy input now uh interestingly
even when it was started it was a little
three volt battery tiny little battery
so this is quite ingenious you could
certainly uh it's probably not as robust
it can't be like put in a vehicle in
mood because it's tuned to this
frequency of on the earth you know
anywhere you go on Earth there's a
magnetic field frequency so his system
is dependent on that being tuned others
are not others are not so there are many
ways to scan this cap but this was a
very fascinating but again he had made
every conceivable strategic mistake to
guarantee it will never benefit Humanity
and so in a way it was a case in uh
looking at of course this guy is you
know quite up there in years now
um he's also you know a scientist but he
he really thinks he's going to somehow
beat the power grid companies by
creating a megawatt plant and selling it
to the
selling it to the utilities I said no
those companies are vertically and
horizontally integrated into people who
do not want this solution and the laws
around and regulations around tapping
into the Grid or so regulated by state
federal and local bureaucracies that
they'll kill this and strangle it in its
great cradle in two seconds so what I
find is that you find these ingenious
devices attached to completely wacky
strategies because they're they're not
figuring in their strategy of how to get
it out what their adversary is capable
of and then here's your big mistake you
cannot underestimate your adversary and
your adversary is you know got more
power and wealth than the entire US
government and very exotic Technologies
to get in your way I mean when I say
exotic the studying of this sort of
Science and Technology what the cie guys
call wsfm this whole area of science is
Weird Science and freaking magic what's
it called again repeated once more
wsfm if you ever hear that term in the
Carters of some contractor it's a weird
science and freaking magic
um at Northrop Grumman they just call it
pfm pure [ __ ] magic excuse my
language but uh but but they call it
magic because you have all this
phenomenon that happens it's not magic
it's just like it's it's new science
um but let me interject if you don't
mind I'd like to get into the weeds I
know that you want to get out of the
ways let's just delve into for a tiny
bit so how does one produce the voltage
that's required
the millions or tens of millions of
volts like practically well some of them
don't need that but some of them do like
at this gentleman he just had a starter
once he tapped into the frequency
and the magnetic field right there he
would have this small three volt battery
to start the initial resonance in these
plates there's a group up in Canada that
has a very similar system so not all of
them have to have that but your some of
your classical uh systems for example T
Townsend Brown and his ability to create
this lifter of anti-gravity effect or
gravity control effect
you're talking to a classically trained
person I have issues with the zero point
so for instance you need a difference it
doesn't matter if there's energy around
you and then if there is then why
doesn't it create a black hole because
then you would need Quantum field Theory
and general relativity so there are many
questions that arise if you don't mind
just like what is it what is meant by
what is what is this frequency and
what's meant by tapping into the
frequency
it's what what I'm trying to say in late
terms so I mean I don't know how far to
if you have let's say you have a two
million volt
uh system but very low current you know
so yeah maybe it's only you know static
electricity by the way is millions of
volts like when it's cold and you you
zap that's millions of volts but an
incredibly low power because there's not
much current
if you have a sustained uh voltage like
that at certain frequencies hurt cycles
per second
it will create
basically as some have described it a
vector a perturbation of the Ambient
Energy field and cause
as as Maury King describes that sort of
this cavitating effect uh from the zero
point where it actually pulls out some
little bit of it now remember it's been
estimated that you know at the level of
Zero Point Energy uh the the volume of
of inside a coffee mug that much space
amount of space has enough potential
power to boil off all the Waters of the
planet
minor liquidity here static electricity
is on the order of fifteen thousand
volts and not a million or tens of
millions I believe Dr Greer simply
misspoke as we all do and I'm correcting
here in part so that you don't go trying
to build a device wondering why the heck
is not working or ruining your family
dinners with physics tidbits like I do
so it's it's you know this is why you
test to kind of referred to it although
they didn't understand that's what it
was this sort of infinite energy field
but to actually access it you have to do
these uh various physics and
electromagnetic engineering uh
techniques and it's different for
different substances if it's just
electric steel which is what Dr Holcomb
is doing with his Holcomb Energy System
that's different from what this
gentleman in the desert was doing with
the magnetic field of the earth which
was different from what Stan Meyer was
doing with water but the principles you
know the UN this is why you know one of
the things I've been advocating is some
Venture capitalists who actually you
know you know there's billions of
dollars being spent on pseudo solutions
that someone puts together
and this is also going to be one of the
appeals we're going to make an open
source
physics research and development lab
funded to you know 50 to 100 million
dollars to start with so that you can
put the best people in place study these
devices that have come and gone and
optimize it into a solid-state system
that's stable that could begin to be
moved out to the public I think that if
you had such a facility and support and
it was done open source you'd probably
would have uh at least your first system
developed within one to two years uh and
and at that point it would have to be
massively disclosed is there any way of
working with the Galileo project on
something like this
I don't think that they're focusing on
this or looking for things way out there
and and they're they're folks associated
with that project that are uh embedded
counterintelligence people would you
would be willing to to have Galileo's
equipment present during a ce5
Expedition
uh I don't I haven't drilled down on
what their equipment is I think they're
still very linear
and they're looking at things like the
electromagnetic space above the the
sensors they're watching for things in
the sky they have various cameras that
will triangulate uh anything that it
sees
um and they're really not
um you know differentiating between
whether they see a build or something
anomalous they want to gather all the
data they can avi's a friend so I can
set something up like I'm I'm just
curious what the answer would be well
it's it's certainly possible I think
some of that equipment could be very
useful during a ce5 event remember most
of what happens is trans-dimensional
um it's coming back and forth from one
dimension to another Trend transits
Dimensions
um anything that's truly Interstellar is
not going through a straight line of an
electromagnetic field
um but that means part of it is that the
whole understanding of the phenomenon is
flawed because they're trying to
interpret some technology that's 10 to
the 6th to 10 to the ninth years further
along than ours are
um
using
nominally more sophisticated
understanding of physics and what
existed during the time of Einstein and
relativity in quantum physics and that's
not going to cut it
um because now we get into what the
ultimate Singularity is which is the
Consciousness field and the plasticity
of space and time and how all this sort
of phenomenon happens but so the
question is you have to design your
equipment
understanding a broader Spectrum now one
of the good things about modern cameras
with light cells the ccds or wherever
they are
those actually perceive and pick up data
much better than the human eye by far
and so that's one of the things we've
been developing is you know how do you
use those in a setting where an event
might be happening and there's some
prodromal some indication there's
something around you and you can then
image it with these sort of cameras at
what setting uh what's optimal what's
the exposure all that so you know if
they have information on that well they
may certainly be happy to share with
them what our experience has been also
in full disclosure I don't operate
cameras at all I'm you know I run the
other way and give me a defibrillator
you know but
um but that's that's something that you
have to be very useful but I think you
have to begin to look at it
everyone's trying to force around the
peg in a square hole when it comes to
the science and physics of this they're
not looking broadly enough
why would civilizations that are
hundreds of thousands to millions of
years more developed than we are be
using the physics that you no offense or
Avi would understand they're not so you
have to be open up to the possibility of
of how these sorts of phenomena happen
and then what are the conditions that
optimize them because as you get
increasingly into uh the the ultimate
non-locality and entanglement is the
Consciousness field and that is by the
way here's a hint that is the
singularity but it actually is
quantifiable for example the
communication systems between these
Interstellar civilizations are actuated
they have devices but they're
interfacing
at the level of the quanta of thought
and Consciousness I'm not talking Elon
Musk with a chip in your brain sort of
thing turning on your computer but very
advanced
um what we call technology assisted
Consciousness and the other way around
Consciousness assisted Technologies and
and those and so so all of that you know
if you're sitting out there sterily
trying I'm being doctor or whatever
um and you're you're you're locked into
a virtually one notch better than
Newtonian physics
you're not going to get very far because
you're not dealing with you know humans
from 2022.
now the people who the people in
classified projects would understand
this uh because they've been studying it
for a very long time down to the level
of the the you know science and the
Technologies
um but knowing that information is
useful to a research team like the
obvious because if they know that
information they're going to be able to
get some very good Clues on how to set
up their experiments and set up their
reconnaissance systems
firstly if it's a nominal increase in
physics from let's say Newton or
Einstein how is it achieved by someone
like Tesla Nikola Tesla and then and
then secondly when it comes to the volts
is it the static like the same volts
that's involved in static electricity or
is it of the order of Millions
it really depends on what you're using
what the substrate is you know you're
doing this through water you're doing
this through uh a crystalline material
are you doing it through a nano
crystalline material it varies this is
why it has to be it's sort of like a
tuning of the voltage combined with the
the frequency and that's that's where
you get some very major breakthroughs
and those principles if they're
understood and you look at these uh
technologies that have come in and gone
for 100 years there's a definite pattern
of now I'm not saying that all those
guys understood what was going on I
don't know if any anyone does yet
um frankly uh because but then I point
out you know as a medical doctor which
we tend to be very much more practical
uh we use uh the Johnson thought Fox
club for heart failure because it
increased the contractile strength of
the muscle for a hundred years before we
were able to figure out what the
mechanism of action on the you know very
fine chemical and cellular molecular
cellular level was aspirin well from the
bark of a tree right aspirin had certain
known observed effects but it was fairly
recently actually that it was understood
how aspirin works so you have to
understand that
in a complex
trans-dimensional universe
you're going to see effects and let's
just say results of certain empirical
configurations of electromagnetics and
frequencies and voltages and what have
you and it may be 50 or 100 years later
that you fully understand
how it's happening
um but I think this is this is why I
this is why I try to avoid people who
get into these physics arguments of how
many angels are dancing on the the head
of a pen because most people don't
realize that there's a great many things
we use in our society that we actually
don't know how they work we just know
they do work all right what kind of
Aesthetics is similar right yeah there's
all kinds yes all kinds of uh and I
think doctors are more comfortable with
Athen physicists because it's a much
more dynamic system uh because you have
a human being who's conscious and there
are all kinds of phenomena associated
with the mind and the body and the
neurons in the heart and the brain and
all of this and so
um I I think that the approach to it has
to be much broader uh than what people
think would be now from just an
electromagnetic engineering point of
view I think the reason so many of these
have been stumbled upon by people over
the last
100 plus years is is that it's once you
start playing around let's say and
experimenting it's empirical with
certain types of materials and certain
types of electronic frequencies
you get into some phenomenon I mean up
to and including bringing tapping into
other dimensions that could bring
Critters From Another Dimension into
this Dimension I mean they did this at
the cube at the Lockheed the Skunk Works
uh and I I know also at a couple other
labs that have
yeah but this gets into stranger things
I'm sure some people would be thinking
like okay that's a huge claim a huge I'm
not of the sort that says huge claims
require huge evidence because evidence
is evident it's not like there's huge
evidence and and diminutive evidence so
but either way like evidence is evidence
and I'm curious so do you mind
expounding on this claim of if you tap
into so and so
physics I'm unsure what that precisely
means but if you tap into so and so
physics under certain configurations
a dimension has opened up and different
entities can come in or go out yeah like
please expand on that and then and then
with the key of of technicality if you
can because like that's what this
podcast is known for equations if you
can if there are I know that's a strange
thing to ask I don't think physicists
are anywhere near as close-minded as you
suggest you know there's many ideas
Multiverse String Theory those are far
from Newtonian mechanics and you
mentioned Maxwell and pointing vectors
if just manipulating those or what's
required or some other Factor needs to
be added that was taken out by heavy
side it's not as if that's not known to
physicists or out of the realm of what
they would accept playing with and so on
okay so anyway going back to this
assertion about the entities coming in
and out well again you know I I it what
what they did experimentally is they
would have a very similar toroid device
and
that a certain frequency and voltage and
there are you could you know there the
algorithm for this would be millions of
that could be combined they would have
weird stuff like stranger things or
Montauk Boom come into the lab and this
I know three different Labs where this
has happened they can also alter space
time there's a guy down in the near the
Redstone Arsenal that had one of these
systems and it would actually snap time
you know so the environment around where
he was working altered uh off the
timeline back and forth
uh very very unusual uh phenomenon and
that guy uh brilliant physicist and
engineer
he works through a contractor for the
CIA but uh and I've been in his skiff
and and where he does his work
so uh now again I'm not I don't build
these systems I understand the
principles how they work but that kind
of phenomenon has been observed by
people in these specialized labs for
gosh I mean decades switch laps three
Labs which of them the Lockheed Skunk
Works in the cube this skiff that's down
near the Redstone Arsenal and the uh the
old Montauk operations
a long island is this related at all to
what's happening at skinwalker
yes because remember Skinwalker
was a Native American known area of
unusual phenomenon contact there's a
gentleman named uh Bob Bigelow Robert
Bigelow who I first met at the
Rockefeller Ranch in 1993
who uh along with some of his Sidekicks
uh
Colonel John Alexander and others wanted
to acquire that property and in the
Rancher didn't want to sell it so they
set up a lot of this
uh weird wsfm electromagnetic phenomenon
that was scariest [ __ ] and the guy
relented and eventually sold it it has
since been resold to another person of
course I guess has been sensationalized
in some TV show but the uh there's a lot
of activity going on underground there
but we were out there about a year and a
little over a year ago and observed uh
late night uh what very much sounds like
under under this facility Drilling
um and uh building of something deep
underground and my understanding it's
sort of like the um
uh the Brad uh the Bradshaw Ranch in
Sedona they got taken over by and turned
into a black site so I think that the
Skinwalker Ranch has all kinds of weird
phenomenon that has to do with this kind
of experimentation and that it has
nothing to do with what was innately
there prior to uh so I think this is
again often when there's something quite
interesting happening like that you have
people from who are fronting for the
intelligence Community or being
manipulated by them who then acquired as
an asset
um and so that you know sort of what's
called capture where it'll get you know
they'll try to capture that and then use
it to their own purposes and whatever is
going on after they get involved it has
a faint resemblance to what was there
prior
to the acquisition so my understanding
is that we went out there and did
actually a close encounter of the fifth
kind C5 contact event uh in June of 2021
very interesting yeah well no on a Mesa
overlooking it so we were near it we
weren't on the property so we're talking
in the U inter Basin yeah
well it was on a some private land
adjacent to and sort of above where the
ranch would be if you went down so yeah
same in in Basin book very close
and uh
so so I mean you know
nothing all that extraordinary except we
did observe
um this sound of drilling and of course
it it reminded me of uh back in the 80s
you know the new agers were going on
about the Taos hum uh and you know
around Taos New Mexico and
um and out in that area of Northern New
Mexico and of course that was a Bechtel
uh nuclear-powered tunneling machine
making the connector between Los Alamos
and the Dulce area which cannot be
accessed from the ground or above but
only from a tunneling uh and that was uh
you know that device was brought on in
the 60s 70s but it's and of course it's
classified it's nuclear powered so
people would not like the idea of some
nuclear-powered thing running under
their uh land but that's how you connect
say from Edwards to Nellis or Los Alamos
to Dulce and so it sounds like from what
I understand you know that that's
happening at the skin walker Ranch
probably connecting out to another
facility like The dugway Proving Grounds
or someplace like that
in Utah dugway is a very key I mean
certainly I think that much more
significant than so-called Area 51 is
this newer underground dumb as they're
called Deep Underground military base
operations out near dugway you know you
spoke a little yeah okay there's this
claim about the Atacama mummy that it
was faked or that junk science was done
on it and foreign
when I was doing some research into this
there's four Stanford professors where
specialists in DNA and genomics and
pediatric disorders and so on graduate
students pull stocks and so on so that
helped analyze and collect the data so
what's your evidence for claiming that
it's fake why do you say that well the
principal person who said he would do
the testing on it at Stanford he got a
three three and a half million dollar
teal Grant sort of a made-up Grant from
the Department of Defense about the time
I handed off the genetic sample at that
point there were people who don't want
to be named who offered to help them do
it on what's called ancient DNA ancient
doesn't mean thousands of years old but
in other words it's desiccated and it's
from a deceased creature
um he refused that help uh one of the
men who evalued that gentleman and a man
who worked with Watson and Crick and has
many many patents and is one of the
Premier geneticists in the world looked
at their data actually went into the
database and it was quite clear that it
was skewed and defrauded and altered but
because they were able to get these guys
names on that uh yeah if you look at we
they're on our YouTube channel there's
an entire expose about this and what the
reports are and I've left the guy's
names off of it because they don't want
to be attacked for having pointed out
the fraud that would happen at UCSF in
Stanford which I'm not proud to say I
have a daughter who got her phds at UCSF
but I have a daughter Stanford so I mean
I just think that it's a tragedy that
this happens science happens all the
time and the whistleblowers who know
about it often have their career is
ruined
but I think that that was a classic case
of junk science being pushed forward as
results and it wasn't
so if you if you're an expert in that
area and you don't look at just the text
of the paper but actually drill down now
we still don't know what this Atacama
creature is I have no idea what it is I
never said it was alien I just said that
it doesn't conform with any known
organism and in fact
a Dr lockman Who is the um you know kind
of world's expert on genetic bone
deformities said definitively and this
is in our reports on our website that
this was a a creature that was at least
six years of old by looking at the bones
and the epiphyseal closures you know
where the bones the growth plates and
and their development it'd be the
equivalent of a six-year-old human in
terms of its bone development let me be
clear it just so it's the claim that he
lied for money is that the claim or or
that he didn't know exactly what he was
doing what is the
we don't know it needs to be uh
investigated you know we have
recommended that Stanford and UCSF and
and uh Cold Spring Harbor the the where
they published the article originally uh
launch an investigation
um because there's something that is
very not right with this
and this is according to people who are
way past my specialty as a doctor who
are real renowned experts and genetics
and molecular biology where they clearly
can prove that this was deliberately
done improperly so would they be willing
but these are the anonymous people
you're referring to or oh I'm sure they
would that they would succumb to a
subpoena they're not going to be on a
salacious UFOs show or something where
would they write a peer review paper
where other people not involved you know
with some lab could I asked them to but
I think they're they're intimidated they
see this big machine of disinformation
running them over and one of them has
his own biotech company
and uh the other one is is up there in
years and uh he just doesn't want the
grief
you know he's I think he's in his 80s
but I mean he had worked with Watson and
Crick and you know a very renowned
Caltech molecular biologist and
geneticist and you know I've had some
serious people look at it this has been
one of my frustrations we're going to
have to have people who are willing to
you know when you find this kind of
corruption most people don't want to
take on the Scandal and and the
controversy and the blowback that
happens uh because usually you know it's
not a good thing to be a whistleblower
um particularly when you're going up
against a power structure of corrupt
interests so exactly how it happened and
why I have my own Theory
uh but I just point out it's a very
unusual coincidence that they got a
three and a half million dollar kind of
one-off made up deal Grant from the
Pentagon at the time of the handoff of
the genetic material as a logical point
it's not always the case that the money
has a causal effect in some other area
so for instance I'm sure that people
have thrown accusations at do like look
you've raised x amount or you want x
amount or you're given x amount but
you're like that doesn't tarnish what I
do so even if that's the case well but
the the timing is suspicious and forget
about that it's the results if you're if
you I challenge anyone to go into actual
the database attached to that report and
not come to the same conclusion these
other scientists have come to but nobody
does that they just read the paper and
the conclusions they're not going into
the whole methodology and the ones who
have every single one of them have
concluded the same thing so you know
that's water under the bridge I mean
it's just something I've come to expect
from people in Academia
it would it would be great if we could
see a peer review paper come from
somewhere
you find some honest people who aren't
subject to threats and bribes and and
I'll give them I will give them a
retained sample of the DNA okay great
because we have we we think we didn't
give oh trust me
in the beginning you mentioned you would
like people who are afraid for their
lives they have some free energy
Enterprise or or invention to come to
you and and hey there's a 200 trillion
dollar industry of energy or after that
yeah that would come down on them but
you're saying look look I can protect
you and you shouldn't be afraid no no
the protection is the massive disclosure
of see what people don't understand is
that if you keep it secret
and you're the only person that knows or
10 people who know about it you're very
vulnerable
I mean it's just it should be common
sense and you want to get it out of you
know you get that hot potato out of just
your own uh house you want to have it
out there also so that peer review
people can say all right here's the
plans for it let's reproduce it because
this is sent upon of science is
independent verification and
reproducibility that's the other problem
that doesn't happen because people are
conditioned by venture capital and their
investors keep it secret keep it secret
but that really when you're dealing with
a fundamental new area of science that
doesn't work it needs to be put out
there to be checked and reproduced by
other uh people skilled in the art as
they would say of of electromagnetic
engineering and physics so I think
that's that's the recommendation uh it's
a it's a treat it's a strategic
recommendation as opposed to saying I
personally but I could help with that I
know that we could help with that
um but the mistake that they all make is
is taking the advice of lawyers and
businessmen and conventional Venture
Capital people who uh of course are
doing what would conventionally be done
and I would say that if you're inventing
a new iPhone or a new software program
okay maybe that works
um when you're dealing with a technology
that's going to upend the whole Petra
dollar and macro economics structure on
the planet that is based on the type of
energy system we use you're dealing with
a different set of strategic variables
and you have to alter your plan
accordingly but that doesn't happen
they're all making the same predictable
mistakes for 100 years and that's it's a
tragedy and I think we're not going to
change the outcome I don't care who the
person is uh I know that there are folks
like Dr Randall Mills had blacklight
power something like 100 million dollars
um it was all very secretive they
vanished you know I mean you know these
things happen with great periodic
predictability and there are a certain
number of errors that are made over and
over and over and over again and and so
I think that's the problem and the only
way I see out of it
is you either have to have someone who's
well healed enough to buy the technology
out and then open source it or you have
to have a lab that gets created that is
fundamental organizing principle is
academic and scientific and Engineering
cooperation on an open source platform
uh blockchained or something and that
anything that is discovered and verified
is released in real time and keeps and
once you have something operational that
functions then that needs to be
disclosed as I mentioned through all
kinds of creative efforts because the
corrupting influence of folks who want
to keep this quiet I mean there are all
kinds of investigative reports that have
proven how various cartels and corporate
interests can submarine
technology that's going to be a threat I
mean you know don't take my word the the
Federation of American scientists so
about a decade or 12 years ago came out
with a report of over 5 five thousand
patents that have been seized under
National Security orders and one of them
was something that sounds so trivial now
than the 1970s 50 years ago would have
just been a very high efficiency solar
panel more efficient than anything that
was out there but it would have competed
with the price point of oil and coal and
and gas and power from your power
company and so that I know I know you
don't have the patent at hand but what
is this that it's on our website it's in
the movies it's everywhere we have
everything please read
um you know you wave your hand and say
that well where is it it's the America
the Federation of American Sciences uh
it's Stephen after good is the guy who
authored it it's a paper read it 2010 it
came out 20 October 2010 so we're 12
years ago so um it's there we published
it you know the fact that you haven't
seen it doesn't mean it's not there
I'm telling your attitude it's like I am
where is it I said what's there I'm
telling you everything I'm telling you
is there it's out there in open source
let's get some some positive testimony
you've had um you know you were talking
about strategizing earlier and how
um you you know you you've uh built
Bridges with a lot of really great
celebrities who can get the word out and
things like this one of those people
um historically was was Tom Delong who
who helped with to the staff and things
like that and you you guys used to be
chummy and I kind of wanted to ask you
know what happened between you and Tom
why did you drift apart
what we did and he got intercepted by
some folks who had sort of brainwashed
him of the alien threat narratives uh
General mccaskill at Wright-Patterson
and other people and uh he got led by
his nose down that Primrose path and
then of course he had all kinds of of
dark players like Elizondo and uh Simi
band Jim Simi band who's CIA and other
people kind of circle around him and I
think he just got used and abused and
then dumped which I had predicted would
happen it was unfortunate uh but the
problem with having a little bit of
knowledge in this area it's very easy to
get manipulated by these sort of
professional
counterintelligence operatives so when
my what I saw happen is that Tom kind of
got intercepted because they saw him as
someone who could be a front man to open
up this with a certain narrative
to a very specific demographic you know
younger people and I don't know
um with with this sort of these are a
threat to the National Security and oh
by the way we don't know what they are
but of course we do know what they are
we put out a film last year called The
Cosmic hoax that documents how all this
was done
um but I think that in his case I I
actually don't it was quite some years I
mean he's had come out and stayed at my
house out here in Virginia in the
mountains at near University of Virginia
and I've been at his place and we did
some things but that was
I'm trying to think early 2000s or so
what have you
um so I just think that what happened
and and he mentioned some of this to me
when we were out there he had a he was a
girlfriend or
at the time whose uncle was involved in
these projects and I think he started
getting targeted to get pulled away from
you know actually staying on an accurate
path and he got intercepted by
counterintelligence people who are very
good at doing that because that that's
one of the real problems is that if they
look like you could be an asset to be of
some value
then there's going to be an attempt to
pull you over
uh and and feed you false information
but also false narratives but he was
predisposed to that anyway the whole
Alien Invasion thing which I always find
laughable any scientists you know oh yes
you're coming from another star system
with Technologies 100 000 years past
what we have
and they they're invading us how where
the whole thing is ludicrous
um but it's of course how you would
build the future of the military and
Industrial and financial complex around
another enemy because I think that's
exactly what Verner Von Brown shared
with Carol rosin on his deathbed this
has been a long-term defense plan to
sort of present a threat from out there
where the world can get United but
instead of in peace it's going to get
united through another Boogeyman we all
need to fight because ultimately the
public is controlled through fear and
demagoguery and and this is the ultimate
demagoguery and fear in my opinion just
for the record I apologize if my
attitude is dismissive I don't mean that
and when I ask for evidence or for a
paper I do that with everyone including
aviloby said that so-and-so came from
outside
I didn't bring a 500 000 page archive in
here to hold up every time you ask about
something but I've given people the
resources go and find it
um you know now eventually what we want
to do with this is a PDF searchable
archive where all this will be you know
you put in boom and it comes up that'd
be great yeah yeah so you guys since you
guys are rich podcasters can help fund
that I wish I'm just gonna because we're
talking about you know 500 000 to a
million dollars to create that uh this
one's from uh Abdul Aziz uh he says
thank you so much Dr Maria God bless you
and keep on doing what you're doing it's
very important he asks what is your
answer to the people who accuse you of
doing things like vacancy five events
with flares and who complain about
charging a lot of money for your ce5
events
well actually anyone can do ce5 with an
app that took 20 years to develop that's
on all the stores so it's like nine
dollars or something so most of which
goes to the app developers and and the
Apple but so you don't have to come with
need anything you do it yourself
um so that's just a ridiculous moreover
on the YouTube channel all that
information is there now the events we
do
uh fund the disclosure project and what
we're doing
so I live on ninety thousand dollars a
year that's a big pay cut from six
hundred thousand a year as the chairman
of emergency medicine how much of a pay
cut asks this guy how much should pay
cook he's taken when other people take a
eighty percent pay cut to do this work
they can then talk to me
um so otherwise just say thanks now the
reality is if you're going to run an
organization
that has expenses you're going to have
to charge for things you know and so
this is one of these really stupid
questions in my opinion it's like I have
been advised that everything I'm doing
should be ten times
more costly than they are there's almost
90 plus percent of everything we've ever
done has been done for free and is out
there in the public for free
um and that is not the way to build you
know financially an organization that's
taken on what we are this is why we
don't have any paid staff
or an office so in reality uh you know
we just did a workshop well it cost 150
000 with today's inflation to engage the
venue
and they made us buy all kinds of food
for the attendees and it was 150 000 so
I don't have someone saying we will
underwrite the cost of everything so you
can do these things for people for free
now maybe the person asking that
question is a billionaire who could
underwrite the expenses for all these
events and if he is great you haven't
give him a call otherwise in the real
world let's talk real world in the real
world you're not going to be able to put
on uh have an organization uh and do
something like the disclosure project or
if I have to bring uh some top secret
military whistleblowers in and it's at
my expense I do not ask the government
to pick up this expense where is that
going to come from my retirement savings
so yes there are fees
where the money can come from
oh really good yeah so again
um
please
if you have a way of getting free energy
or you know someone who who does you can
set up a Bitcoin Farm because one of the
most costly aspects is the electricity
and then you can fund
as much research as you like or at least
a significant portion of it so is there
are you looking into that is there a
reason that I don't have I don't have
one of those devices you didn't hear me
let me repeat it again we have
investigated and seen enough that
they're all entrapped in a team of
people the inventor and his team that
are wanting to keep it secret
um now one of them that we recently
visited in fact was running Bitcoin
mining machines
man that's how that in fact there was
one little shed that it was in and
that's what he was using it for
he was mining Bitcoin so yeah so
certainly that could be done
um but I don't actually own or possess
one of those systems you know
I mean if we did that'd be the least
important way of generating Revenue I
think that there's actually uh billions
of dollars available uh from people who
do want to have an environmental
solution that would flow into any
operation that could widely approve but
here's the other problem if you're not
willing to open it up to Scientific
scrutiny it isn't going to be taken
seriously
you know all right so that's why like
with the disclosure project I say don't
take my word for it here are these 5 000
documents here are these dozens of
military Witnesses here's this now if
you have a device you can't make a claim
uh that's this Grand claim that it's
doing this and there's nobody who's a
third party entity that's credible who
has reproduced it or checked it so a lot
of times they want to go straight from
the invention to trying to monetize it
and there are all these other steps and
the the big one is the opens disclosure
of it open source but also the
scientific Recreation of it by
independent people who don't have an ax
to grind aren't trying to raise money so
that is something that always should
happen in science but that has not
happened properly with this because a
friend of mine who's a venture capital
guy he said there's a direct
relationship between how important the
invention is
and how crazy the inventors get so when
you when you've hit something like the
gold the brass the Golden Ring here and
that it becomes they become more and
more erect because they know what they
have
and they know what its value should be
and so it that sort of bloodlust
overwhelms The Logical mind uh and this
and the scientific mind and they feel
like they're against everyone or to them
against the world in reality the whole
world would be with them one of the
things I point out there are a
relatively tiny number of people on the
planet that benefit from the status quo
of how the planet is running
but there's 99.99 or more of the
population that would be behind you if
you would open it up and disclose it and
then money ain't going to be an issue
because if it's disclosed open source
and it's proven by independent I mean
look if someone makes a claim like that
they put all the information out there
will probably be a hundred different
labs and people who will verify it I
mean if it's put out Faithfully
unfortunately a lot of these people put
out everything but the secret sauce
so I know I know over a couple patents
out there like Stan Meyer did this where
he put everything but and he actually
falsified the voltages and the hurts and
whatnot of his uh uh electrical device
and that of course caused people to try
to reproduce and it wouldn't work uh so
I think that these sort of little legal
and financial tricks always end up being
counterproductive frankly to to what
their objective is
um anything that keeps it in a small
secretive group
um trying to monetize it you know knew
my analysis here's to my analogy
DARPA created what's something called
the internet not Al Gore but DARPA did
now that was done by government it
sorted let's call it open source
internet right get on the internet
the worldwide web we need the equivalent
of that but it ain't going to come from
the government it's not going to come
from an academic Institution
we need the equivalent of a an organ
organization that's going to do this
research and development on these
Technologies in an open source way
that's shared openly and the technology
the platform the initial one I call this
phase one is widely available now that
would not prevent even if it's a private
Corporation from after that initial
launch doing very profound refinement
let's call it generation 2.0 or 3.0 or
10.0 of the device
because that's how science goes forward
you know eventually uh most of these
early devices were rotary and
electrostatic rotary all four of the
ones that I'm talking about are solid
state
they're solid state no moving Parts
which is beautiful
yeah um some some guys in the audience
just wanted us to to just give it like a
high yes or no uh the question I
previously asked uh where someone
mentioned about dropping flares I just
want to check so you refute that claim
like no place
we've never done something like that
ever
now I do think we've had a few events
where
people have tried to trick us
and that's different uh and what do you
mean
where they've tried to Stage things
so that we'd be fooled as in
participants that came to your events
it's no outside yeah okay
yeah okay and we've gotten pretty good
at finding who those when that happens
but would you like to name and Shane
people like who like the government or
or the participants or what well again
the government which government
no the participants who come never would
do something like that
um but you know what I'm really
encouraging people is to people to get
get the app at ce5 contact app and do it
themselves you know I got a great report
recently from uh truck driver in Croatia
who was driving along and doing it took
a break of and was doing the ce5 uh
techniques and this uh ET crap
materialized to the left of his cab and
floated right over the cab and vanished
and we're getting reports like this from
people all the world so I tell people
you don't have to be with me I think if
anything due to the fact that there's a
lot of reconnaissance around what I'm
doing you're probably better off if I'm
not there
um I do like teaching people the
concepts and the techniques
of remote viewing and the meditative
techniques and what the cosmology is
that we're engaging uh and to me that's
like we're a big part of this needs to
come in is a whole revisiting of the
cosmology that it you know takes it out
of straight-line Universe
um because we're not dealing with the
straight-line universe we're dealing
with a Quantum holographic conscious
universe and uh that's a that's a very
different kettle of fish when you start
dealing with civilizations who certainly
understand that and their Technologies
are utilizing aspects of them
so um to me that's really exciting I
like it's still the thing that I love
doing the most actually but
um but you know there's a limit to how
much time I can take to do those so I'm
encouraging other people to do it and
you know it's not difficult to do
actually
is the is the app 100 required or are
there other methods that people can use
well if you don't if you know what
you're doing you don't need the app if
you are trying to learn about it get the
app so it's like a shower essentially
like a bit of guidance
oh yeah it's a whole it's like a
meditation app you like just like some
people don't know how to meditate
they're like just get an app and no it's
more than that it's like how do you set
up the group what equipment do you have
what you know how do you different
satellites from other objects no it's a
whole training program
oh yeah okay so I personally would love
to speak to Bob Lazar I request him
frequently well we'll see what happens
but anyway what are your and I'm always
getting people's different opinions on
on Bible talks people seem he's a
divisive figure so do you happen to have
any stories about bubbles are anything
that you've heard any opinions on him
well here's something that is a one
since I'm up the street from the white
house right now at my place in
Washington uh Eleanor Roosevelt said
small minds talk about people
mediocre Minds talk about events great
minds talk about ideas
so
um I'm not someone to get into sort of
you know the gossip Mill of talking
about personalities it's not important
what I will say is there are assets
there where he was located I wasn't
there with him nor have I gotten anyone
that corroborate his exact story
but I have people who have corroborated
related
uh facilities and assets that are there
the ones that are underground are the
Extraterrestrial Vehicles above ground
there are places where we are storing or
building the man-made UFOs
um and so we certainly know where those
are and how they're configured and which
areas out by pahoot Mesa and other other
locations
um I have a colonel who's coming forward
who was an early U2 spy plane pilot but
who had been assigned to work with the
Skunk Works lucky Skunk Works and was
had Ben Rich's cell number and was also
at the so-called Area 51 facility uh
observing this so you know it's not
implausible that he was there
um but since I wasn't there with him and
I don't know anyone who was there with
him I just have to you know take his
account and put it into the Matrix of I
call it a mosaic where you're putting
I'm trying to put together the Mosaic
from a million data points and 1100
people incredible people who've been in
facilities and then what you look for
are corroboration points of
corroboration and data points that line
up
um so some some of what he's recounted
would conform with the fact that those
assets are there
to the extent that his physics theories
about how it operated uh I'm not so sure
if those are accurate only because
they've never been tested and moreover
um he was there for such a short period
of time as a young guy I don't think he
would have been read into that
um I I'm not sure if that was just one
of the things I'm always worried about
is that they're onboarding you into
these projects they will give you a
certain amount of information exposure
and disinformation
to deliberately uh it's a testing Pro
it's a testing process I know what the
procedures are how do you manage that uh
Dr Greer with with because there's like
you say there's a lot of elements that
are trying to put out misinformation
disinformation and we each have our kind
of uh tests for what passes through our
filter what what's yours
if I find somebody is providing
something that is factually inaccurate
then they are dismissed from the project
it's a very strict
[Music]
um
you know rule I mean I'm not going to
name names but when we were doing the
briefings for members of Congress in 97
the private briefings that we were doing
prior to the disclosure project in 01 uh
there was a guy who came who some of his
story checked out and then he started
telling embellished aspects of it and we
escorted him out of the facility because
it was completely too risky what you
find the other thing I have found is
some people who have seen one little
piece of something
they then Google the internet or talk to
other people and they start embellishing
um from you know the rubbish that's on
the internet and believe me on this
subject is 90 plus percent nonsense so
uh at least uh and so and in fact
algorithms push the nonsense and the
truth gets left behind
um because salacious gossipy nonsense is
what gets pushed to the front of all the
uh internet platforms because it's click
bait for ad Revenue you know I sell
Facebook Twitter Reddit all of them work
that way so uh that is that's a real
test and that's just a process you have
to go through now you know like the guys
that are surfaced I said well give me
your dd214s and let's check out who you
were and I have some people who helped
investigate their background
um and oh you can do all that and then
at some point if the person has become
an Aficionado of the UFO subject after
they left a command or after they were
working on something they may start
dragging into their narrative this you
know sort of the Cesspool of gospel the
nonsense and conjecture so I think one
of the things we have to be very careful
of is always say what did you see I'm
very hard-nosed about this what did you
personally see or know about and learn
when you were in that facility or when
you were working on this project I'm not
interested in your theories of the
universe no offense and I'm not
interested in what you've dredged up
from other people third hand
so you want us that you have to be very
disciplined and I because I have a
responsibility because I'm handing this
off to key people in DC that it's let's
just stick to what you know we don't
need conjecture
um and it's not your job to do the
assessment it's our job to do the
assessment after we have you know
thousands of data points and evidence
and information so it's very hard a lot
of people because they they get a lot of
attention from
um something that's an amazing event
they witness or a place they saw and
it's very easy for human nature then to
say well
now let me add to it this and this and
this because it's exciting it kind of
keeps the buzz going
um and and I think we that's what we
have to be very careful of in this field
because it is very Sensational and uh
it's easy to get on that slippery slope
where people you know combine and
co-mingle what they directly knew and
what the facts are with other
information that's speculative or
embellished so I think with all of these
sort of uh whistleblowers and Witnesses
it's we have to be prudent careful about
that of course I try to be
that's good to know
um in 1994 Dr Ray Bush and if I'm saying
that right and Linda Hall heard from two
men who who showed uh Dr Ray
identification from the Department of
Defense they claimed that in certain
black programs we were communicating
with non-human entities
trying to control them and exploiting
information provided by certain on human
entities online control weapons but
these alleged Department of Defense
sources instead felt that the non-human
entities were controlling and
manipulating us and we were a big issue
for Humanity can you add any of your own
information to that and if any let us
know if any technology related to
Advanced propulsion and flight was
gleaned from these non-human sources and
through any black programs and do you
feel that these non-human entities may
be manipulating Humanity
um and that our black Tech is so
Advanced that we can see things that we
can't see with our eyes
well there's a whole bunch of issues all
at once certainly there are technologies
that we can see that we don't have to
have our eyes to see it um the
microscope for example in the telescope
but also trans-dimensional systems we
know that uh my military advisor one of
them was at the White Oaks Naval
facility in the 70s and there was a
machine console that was was able to
extract what they call the white noise
of space-time uh anything that happened
or is happening at that moment at any
point in space or happen last year or a
thousand years ago or a million years
ago and that was almost 50 I think it
was 74 or 73 something like that so we
know that those Technologies exist
whether there are these
entities that are behind that it's
titillating and salacious and I have not
seen evidence of it except to the extent
that there are definitely
non-extraterrestrial
when they say non-human that doesn't
mean extraterrestrial so this is where
there's this whole big confusion
it's like if not everything that goes
bump in the night is an extraterrestrial
I mean there's such a thing as
Poltergeist
um you know I've seen things in the ER
that would blow people's minds when
someone has died suddenly and and
violently
um so I I think that it sounds like
there's a great story there would you
mind your Liberation a little bit
oh it was this one of these bizarre
things where this man had been uh you
know another stab or shot anyway he came
in code blue and Flatline we tried to
save him and we couldn't and he then was
taken he was in the trauma room one and
it was taken down to the morgue
um and about three or four or in the
morning I'm out in the center of with my
nurses and all of a sudden that room is
totally empty
cabinets fly open IV bags are being
hurled on the floor uh EKG machine is
turning on by itself it was clearly and
this this guy very angry and was on a
rampage in in that little room and of
course the nurses and I looked at each
other and says we're not going to put
this in the chart but um you know you
see things like this periodically so one
of the problems with the whole UFO
subculture and I think this is this is
done deliberately in my opinion is this
conflation of everything that's not
human it's either human or alien so I
never use the word alien alien to me are
all kinds of phenomena
extraterrestrial may be one of them uh
non-corporeal entities uh or an entity
From Another Dimension that isn't
extraterrestrial meaning and even an
extraterrestrial biological entity from
a star system when a physical star
system and Planet but there are other
dimensions and so there can be all kinds
of phenomena that began to be observed
and under certain conditions very
physically in this Dimension uh have an
effect that isn't extraterrestrial and
so this is why I keep getting back to
this Central Point that we have to
develop a new cosmology I wrote a paper
in the early 90s called ETS in the new
cosmology where we have to develop this
sort of a whole phyla like you know your
biological font you know the groupings
of families the plants and animals
dealing with the cosmos because it is
not just a physical 3D Cosmos there are
these other dimensional uh aspects and
beans and intelligences from other
dimensions but where it gets very tricky
is that if you are an Interstellar
civilization you're not getting from
point A to B at the speed of light you
go beyond the speed of light there's res
that resonance and frequency you're
moving into another dimension and you're
traversing other dimensions so there are
there are from just a phenomenological
point of view what you might observe a
lot of what's extraterrestrial may look
very similar to a poltergeist event and
vice versa and vice going the other way
so this is where knowledge is power and
uh you have to have I think a certain
amount of knowledge about all these
different distinct phenomena plural to
understand what part of it is man-made
which is very important I mean 70 years
and trillions of dollars in Black
funding they have the ability to do
things that would look very much like
it's alien
that's what abductions are and
mutilations are about cattle mutilations
I'm always interested why are they
associated with the craft I don't know I
I don't have a
like even a hypothesis on that so what
do you think about cattle mutilations
well I I do it based on the science that
Dr alt Schuler
whose stuff was ripped off by the
charlatans in the UFO subculture uh he
did the original snippy the horse Case
in Colorado and he was a hematologist
pathologist or a good friend of mine he
was also by the way the nephew of
General Jimmy Doolittle
it went over to investigate Foo Fighters
for Roosevelt and came back and said sir
those are interplanetary vehicles but at
any rate he uh lived in Denver
and uh he's passed away now he got
cancer and died but he was one of the
very early scientists looking into this
and he concluded it was a highly
classified human
uh deceptive false flag deceptive
indication and warning uh and of course
we knew that was the case and when
people see quote-unquote a UFO around
one of these events well which UFO an
Interstellar one or one out of the
Lockheed Skunk Works I think that there
is this again everyone assumes that
anything going on there with this kind
of phenomenon has to be something we
don't understand that's mysterious it's
a little bit like The Wizard of Oz being
behind the curtain pulling all the
levers scaring the crap out of Dorothy
and the Scarecrow
um they have the ability to Stage things
that look very alien that aren't and as
you know Jacques delay has a Dr belay
has a document from the CIA from 1985
describing the CIA program of quote
unquote
staging alien abductions in Brazil and
Argentina for its psychological warfare
purpose now you know I have a number of
men on my team who actually have been
operationally tactically involved in
those programs so if you have people
with the intention to deceive the public
and particularly the gullible UFO
Community then what happens is that
there can easily stage mutilations and
easily stage abductions and easily stage
all kinds of things
um and people are going to not be asking
the question you know is it real or is
it staged so the very first thing when I
hear something uh now I didn't know this
when I first started the project in 1990
but as I've gotten methods and sources
and assets who have been involved with
this and in this case now there are
documents that you know this is a big
problem because if if they can taint how
people view the subject and what the
database is uh by including a lot of
staged events that are human for their
psychological warfare value you then
have to go back to all your cases and
database
and start over you really have to look
at everything with a fresh look and then
you throw in one more confusing element
and that is this whole interdimensional
question of entities quote unquote or
intelligences that are neither human nor
extraterrestrial
that could be in the play and so you
know this people don't like this because
people like you know simple Hollywood
movie type narratives but it is complex
and and I think that I don't think it's
beyond what people can understand but I
just think that it's not usually talked
about you will go to very few
conferences on this subject where the
whole question of the cosmology and all
the different phenomena that could be
man-made versus extraterrestrial versus
quote alien I use the word alien really
to not denote extraterrestrial so much
as what's being foisted on the public as
extraterrestrial
um and I think that's done very
deliberately because if you can
misdirect people you know there's a guy
I worked with years ago who was the
right hand guy for General Odom who is
the director of the National Security
Agency
and after he left that position he
worked with me and helped analyze
documents and stuff
um
so he knew what things should look like
uh it's particularly the documents that
would come to me that are not officially
Declassified that are still top secret
that that we have and so but he told me
he says yes what we do is go to DDT I
said oh it's like the the poison you
know the whatever it was the insecticide
he says yes but it's not what it stands
for you set up a decoy you distract
people and you trash their efforts DDT
he said we run ddts on people all the
time
um and so if you're sort of like an
actor have you ever had one run on you
oh yes absolutely
more than once I mean I
well you know the the night after I I
met with um
uh
I was meeting with the Crown Prince of
Liechtenstein about Prince Hans Lotto
about Liechtenstein and uh of course he
was trying to convince me of the evil
alien narrative so that we could have
World War III that would bring Christ
back on a flying saucer I mean that was
this whole end of the world
eschatological Armageddon sort of
speaking of World War II I want to ask a
Ukrainian UAP question so I'm just
putting that out there let's continue
please
but that but so that night when I did
buy into it this was in July of 1994.
I was targeted with one of these systems
and it was one that was trying to abduct
Me Out of the my hotel room in St Moritz
Hotel and luckily I I identified it
right away as uh directional energy
weapon that was attempting to to do this
um but you know that with that sort of
nonsense has been played on people for
decades remember we took in Havana
syndrome yes way beyond that I mean the
Havana syndrome stuff would be the very
tip of an iceberg uh
electromagnetic Warfare systems that are
more trans-dimensional and that are uh
dealing with more scalar longitudinal
type
energy and so-called psychotronic
radionic but very Advanced versions of
it
um and those those are what are used
often and deployed along with other
means uh during abduction sequences by
these human
uh well criminals I mean you know I mean
one of the things I'm saying to these
folks here in Washington I said you have
to understand you're going to uncover
the largest recoil in the world
racketeering influence corrupt
organization uh and they have
Technologies and and the means to to
make a lot of trouble and you have to
approach this carefully so the whole
system doesn't get blown to Pieces but
but they have these abilities and I
describe them I go from the sort of easy
to understand anti-gravity device
floating over the desert that looks like
an alien ship that came out of
underground at dugway that's made by
Northrop Grumman or something versus you
know these really esoteric
trans-dimensional systems that are
man-made and that can stage and deceive
people quite easily and they're very
good at this by the way you know and
they've been perfecting it from the 50s
in the early days
they used a short statured guys with
made them up in Hollywood type things on
board uh man-made craft and then would
engage in abductions using so a canister
or some knockout chemical and what have
you but as they develop more and more
capabilities in these electronic warfare
systems they then also created these
sort of robotic
what look like aliens the Grays and you
know I know a number of guys
but very very similar at the level of
almost a nanobiomachine
uh type of thing and those are those are
what your typical abduction sequence
Critters uh you know and we know exactly
you know where they're being made who's
making them how they make them how
they're deployed
um and by the way there was an expose on
this in the 80s before I got on the
scene uh by a researcher uh but of
course he got booed uh out of the system
because it blew up everyone's uh belief
system of the good and the bad aliens
and you know they look they want
everyone to be addicted to some other
narrative to replace racism and uh
division on the planet they want the
humans to be United but against an alien
threat it's a it's a very simple
narrative
um and it's what demagogues have done
you know for thousands of years
consolidate power but this is on a
larger scale than just the British
staging you know and and setting up the
mayores fighting against each other in
museum Island so that they could go in
the breach and Conquer New Zealand so
this you know this is a much more
sophisticated high-tech version of that
but that's but that's been a strategy
that the military planners have done for
thousands of years but in this case
you're dealing with some very Advanced
Technologies quite capable of deceiving
almost everyone involved and that's
that's a problem because ultimately what
that creates uh is you know how do you
begin to have do you have to set up a
system where anything that happens goes
through a whole analysis of uh you know
is it this this this or this and you
know there's a whole set of things that
might be and I don't see that people are
doing that it's a little bit I liken
this to a doctor someone comes in with
chest pain and they're so poorly trained
they have to conclude it's a heart
attack and treat them for a heart attack
when it could be a dissecting thoracic
aneurysm or pleurisy or uh pulmonary
embolus or I mean it could be a hundred
things yeah right it could be all kinds
of things so
um what we have in this subject right
now is a crisis in analytics and
knowledge and information because the
the truth is the strangest things are
real and many of them are human in
origin uh now there are the high
strangeness aspects of the ET uh events
and they're the highest strangest nature
of the interdimensional events the sort
of the Montauk type scenario earlier
when when talking about the Havana
syndrome use the word scalar that stuck
out to me do you mind expanding on that
well you know there there are we look at
an electromagnetic signal as a as a wave
right it's propagating at 186 000 miles
per second
um and so the speed of light is that's
what speed of light is 186 000 miles
every second but it's a waveform but the
scalar longitudinal are actually a point
that goes out longitudinally without the
wave in other words it's a signal
without the wave and therefore it
propagates at significantly greater
velocity than the conventional uh speed
of light but it also can be weaponized
now one of the problems the whole reason
this whole modern era of UFO events
happened is that when we began to
detonate thermonuclear weapons and
atomic weapons everyone knows about the
EMP the electromagnetic pulse what they
don't know is that attendant to that
that is using not we didn't have the
instruments to detect it is is a big
pulse that actually disrupts
trans-dimensionally
ET Communications and transportation in
other worlds in other words it tears the
universe in a way that's very
destructive because of that big pulse is
has attendant to it one of these scalar
type uh frequencies and it's it's very
can be very destructive so that's why
all of a sudden there were all these ET
craft around Los Alamos and uh the
Trinity site White Sands and in
particular Roswell people forget that
the only place that we had
nuclear weapons Atomic weapons actually
at that time in 1947 on Earth was the
Roswell Army Air Base and that's why the
ete craft were there we had hidden in a
new radar Dome uh electromagnetic one of
these directional energy weapons in
there that scrambled those craft and uh
three of them crashed from the best
arcount two of them were recovered right
away one was blown with Smithereens one
continued further west there was another
one I think was not found until uh 1950
or 51 more in the Northwest the
mountains of New Mexico
um but that all if you if you look at
the testimony of Colonel diedrich's son
who back in those days in the 60s on he
was the head of all the atomic energy
Commission Now Department of energy
Atomic facilities and Military it was an
Air Force Colonel and he said oh yes
every single one of our Atomic
processing plants uranium uh uh weapon
storage areas a launch missile
facilities had been surveyed surveilled
by these extraterrestrial Vehicles
because they have such great concern to
not only what they could do to this
planet but when they're detonated they
actually are incredibly disruptive they
kind of rip the fabric of the universe
and that that
makes it very foreboding if the UAP is
in being seen over Ukraine at the moment
what do you think of that what do you
think are they attracted to conflict
are they trying to prevent a disaster a
potential World War III event or
honestly I I have seen just what you've
seen that picture and information I
don't have any other information I do
know
that wherever there's a big risk
of of that something like that happening
they're going to be concerned and
observing it because they not only know
the damage it can cause on Earth but
they know the damage it can cause
elsewhere because again everyone's
everyone's still living in a
straight-line Newtonian World they think
what happens on this little planet here
has no effect on a distant star system
or Galaxy and that's simply not true
when you start getting into non-locality
and entanglement and the entangled
universe but on a macro scale so you
know it's one of these things where we
stumbled across this in the 40s and 50s
with atomic and thermonuclear weapons
but we didn't know what kind of Hornet's
Nest was getting kicked
um so that's a very serious problem and
every Military Intelligence person I
know who's been read into this problem
knows what I'm telling you about that
but that would make sense why you know
you have you have you know Putin
rattling a saber saying he's has because
we dropped bombs on Hiroshima nakasaki
there's a precedent for him to use
weapons at least a smaller tactical
Battlefield sized ones if his country is
threatened uh and now since they he sort
of set up a scam thing to Annex part of
Ukraine now anything that happens in
that part is an invasion of the
motherland of Russia therefore we can
use nuclear weapons so very dangerous
um so it would not surprise me therefore
that there would be both
extraterrestrial and human
Advanced aircraft in there
the man-made the man-made UFOs as well
as the ET ones it seems that a lot of
the control for the disclosure process
is actually in the hands of the others
whoever they may be you know the whole
range of them
um what do you think yeah just you know
the phenomena at large
um no that's not true that is not true
no we didn't say so I was just going to
ask why you think they wouldn't reveal
themselves on mass around the world and
kind of end this process you know
well because you know it's a little
corny it's like the prime directive
first of all if they were to do that
it would induce worldwide panic because
there'd be no context it would be
portrayed as an alien invasion because
you everyone you know the media every
movie Independence Day uh the all the
invasion you know alien from Ridley
Scott all this is going to kick into
people's subconscious to the fore and
they know that this is not how it should
happen it should happen that humans
tell the truth about it for once in our
lives tell the truth deal with it
directly educate each other and begin to
make peaceful contact with them in a
rational way if they were to do now
could they do that of course I mean they
could do something to be booming to be
over could they take out every weapon
system we have instantly yes but this is
not the way of advanced civilization
Center interact with the Primitive one
which is humans I mean we're not a level
one yet we're a level zero civilization
so you know they're not going to do that
because the other problem is if there's
that kind of intervention externally
then we don't evolve we don't learn the
lessons we don't learn what we have to
learn
um to become a more evolved socially
spiritually and materially uh as an
advanced civilization because it's
almost like I have raised four children
now we have our 12th grandchild on the
way if every time that every if every
time that child
was about to fall when it's learning to
walk you stopped it and held it it would
never learn to walk
so so it's it's that's a simplistic
analogy to sort of a cosmic perspective
of a civilization coming from an
agrarian early industrial and now bang
we hit this threshold of advanced
science and physics but unfortunately
our technologies have gotten ahead of
our social and Spiritual Development
meaning that you know we're not socially
and spuriously developed enough to have
these Technologies and not first use
them in a war or in a weapon system like
a thermonuclear weapon so this becomes
to be a real problem because the the
extinction level events that wipe out
and have wiped out prior civilizations
is when the Technologies get ahead of
the social and spiritual Evolution and
development of the people of that planet
so that's where this is another thing
that keeps recurring is that there has
to be the development of Consciousness
the development socially and spiritually
but the problem right now is we're
running out of time for it to happen
sequentially it has to all happen kind
of at once because we're headed over
this Cliff with the biosphere and the
environment and a lot of other problems
including the risk of thermonuclear war
so this is we're at the Crux of a huge
pivotal inflection point in in human
evolution and we really have to figure
out how we're going to manage that so
that's that's why I left my medical
career let's try to see if we could fix
it before it's too late given that these
beings are said to be able to work
through cognitive manipulation and that
level of advancement
um how can we be sure that what we're
presented by them is real that they
don't have ulterior motives and just to
add on to that do you think that all of
the others are benevolent so that
there's a range
um and just because we're touched on and
see five things here I just wanted to
ask if you think there'll ever be a
chance for a ce5 peer review
well I mean people can review what we
have done and what we put out already
um what I think in terms of your other
question is if the the people who are
really addicted to the idea that there
is the whole you know cowboys and
Indians uh good name bad aliens they
don't seem to understand that what part
of that assessment is coming from stage
to this that are deceptive indication
and warnings or false flag
um and I think it's a very
simple to slip into this because humans
always like to have that drama of US
versus them I mean look at how divided
our country is politically that is
something that people feed on that so
how much of that is sort of an
acculturation and a sort of a
brainwashing
and how much of it is objectively real
now having done thousands of hours with
thousands of people doing ce5 all over
the world and adding all kinds of
contact experiences I see no evidence
that any of them are hostile or
malevolent in any way shape or form all
the things that have happened that have
been disturbing in that way have been
man-made copycat you know sort of
CopyCat alien stuff so my objective
analysis of it is I don't I don't see
that that's the case another sort of
intellectual analysis of it and that's
just empirical The Experience we've had
so you know a lot of people sit in their
their houses Googling the internet and
they think they know what they're doing
but they never go out and try to make
contact or observe something in real
time
um but so in doing that now for decades
I don't see any evidence of any of them
are hustle I do think that there have
been a number of staged events that
would make people conclude that they
were uh like the terrible burn victims
and the cash Landrum case which was our
covert Air Force operations out of
Nellis flying and extraterrestrial
vehicle we had captured and they put a
nuclear a a reactor on it because they
couldn't quite figure out the energy
generating part of it and it was being
flown and it malfunctioned and
radioactive junk was failing on on Betty
cash and Landrum and they were
hospitalized and that whole area the
road had to be dug up twice to get rid
of all the radioactivity that was there
but that was a human mishap of a test
flight of an extra vehicle but they were
happy for the media and the public to
say that aliens are poisoning us with
radioactive you see what I'm saying yeah
it was monkeys in the microwave it's not
extraterrestrials yeah and so this is
one of the real problems is that you
have to have you know I tend to take a
very
um skeptical view of a facile that's
sort of superficial analysis of that
until you can get to the root
information from the people who were
there what actually happened here
um and I I think there are many cases
like that so things that have led to
these Grand conspiracy theories
um and fear-mongering uh I think so many
of them are staged or misperceptions of
human events and so I think we have to
be before we start jumping into the
Will Smith and Independence Day let's
kick alien butt category I think we need
to you know be a little more rational
and deliberative and this is why I don't
see any evidence that there is a hostile
or malevolent extraterrestrial group out
there I think there are some rather
trouble some interdimensional beings
you know this is get you get to some of
these people who work in these spooky
programs that are doing uh Satan worship
and devil worship and all kinds of scary
stuff
so where does love Faith and goodness
enter into this it's just the heart of
it
it's the heart of it I mean
um in my opinion going forward as a
civilization higher Consciousness and
love and approaching all of this with a
a wisdom that prevents us from getting
pulled into these manipulative
narratives is is really key but that's
the heart and the higher Consciousness
being able to discern I mean part of
it's intellectual but a lot of it's the
heart
and ultimately this is I think these
visitors from other star systems are
very interested in the human
capabilities in that regard particularly
Consciousness and feeling and heart
um and I think you know the Breakthrough
where they found 30 or 40 000 neurons in
the human heart so there's this
resonance between mind and heart uh
feeling and Consciousness that we can
develop and that ultimately gives you
the ability to see and know and discern
accurately that you can't just
intellectually in in the intellect and
the ego so I think that's really the
guiding star that's the that's the North
Star is the development of higher
Consciousness and also being connected
to
um the love of the the universe of the
planet and of each other so that our
actions are Guided by that not just by
base greed and avarice or hatred or
whatever it is
um but you know people who want to you
know maintain control and manipulate the
population the love and peace don't cut
it I mean they need to have ways to get
people riled up like at a football game
and opposing teams and that's just
another dysfunctional uh Power Dynamic
on Earth that has to get uh
addressed and fixed but ultimately
that's each of us individually have to
fix that
yeah that's a that's a I am running I
have another hard meeting I'm a little
bit over uh well thank you for spending
so much time it's an honor and I thank
you because we went overtime so thank
you yeah I just I just saw that it's
almost 4 20. oh 4 20. okay okay before
you go some people keep saying so what's
your opinion on Richard Doty do you want
to just answer that and then we can
close with a positive message about love
like something practical like what
should everyone watching do so what are
your opinions on Dodie and then clothes
on love
well I mean he's a counterintelligence
he's put out a lot of disinformation but
he's also we were able to get a certain
amount of really important information
out of him which you can see on our um
Channel our YouTube channel uh and he
was able to confirm that they were doing
human abductions and that he was able to
confirm that they were paying off and
bribing the media
um so uh you know I think that in his uh
later years he's been trying to put out
some valuable sort of information about
that
um which I think many people who've been
involved with some of these dark arts
and nefarious activities at some point
they do kind of want to let some of the
truths come out before they get too old
um as far as you know how people can
help I hope you guys will all go to the
lost centuryfilm.com and help us get the
crowdfunding in place we're already in
production on this documentary film we
hope it comes out in the spring maybe
April or May hard to predict that with
Hollywood but
um and we really wanted to be sort of a
big uh a big leap forward in terms of
human awareness of the the kind of
beautiful world we can have if we can
bring these Technologies to Peaceful use
because imagine this in 20 years by the
time my grandchildren are are having
their kids uh we would have a world
without pollution without power lines
without poverty globally
and with a sustainable planet and the
release of the technologies that would
also clean up the oceans and the land
that we've already kind of ruined so
that those are all possible in fact the
the very hopeful message I give people
is that those sciences and Technologies
are extinct they're already on the
planet but there has to be a strategy
and a Groundswell like a Grassroots
movement to bring It Forward because
it's not going to come out the centers
of power never going to shoot themselves
in the foot so if it's gonna if this
change is going to happen it has to come
from us Little Folks like you and me
that are doing this outside these
centers of power and but if we come
together and do it and in right action
and with courage I think we're going to
have in 20 years of extremely different
planet than we have now the alternative
is extinction frankly so I tell people
that whether they're Ohio net worth
person or a scientist you know this is a
very pressing issue and if we didn't
already have the solution you'd be happy
you could be allowed to be despondent
but we do have the solutions and that's
what we want to prove and well you'll
see the backbone of the whole film on
October 25th if you get on the webinar
unfortunately the event itself is sold
out
the links for that will be in the
description so and then great yep yep
the links to that will be in the
description again it's it's lost century
and then it has a closing question for
you if you could spend like two more
minutes or one minute yeah absolutely
final question Stephen you've been so
great thank you Dr gria
um very enlightened and feeling a lot of
information gaps so you briefed uh CIA
director Woolsey
um and he later turned around and said
actually it wasn't breathing it was a
dinner party
I wanted to ask you like a number of
people have said I wasn't really briefed
I wanted to ask you do you know any
reason for that discrepancy
because the subject they don't want to
admit that they had an interest in the
subject was the subject has such high
social a program
you know social uh ridicule and uh the
other part of it is that they don't want
to admit that after they were read in
they were pulled in and then betrayed
the country
all right
so yeah it is and it's the truth
um luckily you know I have the I have
the correspondence and the FedEx that
set up the meeting what the purpose of
the meeting was and I always help people
look in Washington how do you know
they're lying their lips are moving
so I I looked I did I just shrug and go
yeah what do you expect I mean you know
it's been it's you know disassembling
and a disingenuous comments and and
whatnot it I just it doesn't affect me
at all because I'm shocked when it
doesn't happen
that's great but you know I I share the
truth and people may not like the truth
that's the truth is I know it and
um I do think there's a responsibility
to people who who do receive this kind
of information to act on it in a way
that benefits the the human species that
our country and when they don't they
have uh failed to fulfill the duties of
their office
take care sir I appreciate you going way
over time thank you so next time maybe
we can talk about the Wilson docs
there's so many questions about that but
yeah
all right you guys have a good time take
care thank you bye-bye
okay all right Dan how's that
that was great uh it took a while to
find the Rhythm I think but but I think
we got a lot and seven we got a lot of
information from Dr greater yep yep
Justice Bieber was my favorite part I
want to make a hashtag about that
Justice Bieber
I'm grateful that Stephen Curry Dr
Steven Greer spent so much time with us
so I'll take this offline I'm going to
place it back online in about 24 hours
or so and it will be edited with better
audio and a sponsor message like I
mentioned there'll be a sponsor message
at 20 minutes and then 40 minutes they
pay the bills if you don't like that
then you have the option of like
skipping forward there's a time stamp
all of them are time stamped and you can
also go to theoriesofeverything.org and
be a toe member you get an uh you get an
ad free version so so and you support
the podcast like thank you thank you
either way even just this viewage
viewing just you viewing is supporting
thank you Dan is from that UFO podcast
that will also be in the description
that if you like the the total content
you'll love that UFO content
yeah I I think people will find a nice
crossover between our channels um and
Andy conducts the interviews on that UFO
podcast that are very much you know like
this one we we just asked the question
we let the information come out and the
audience can make up their own minds all
right well stick around for like a
couple more minutes and answer any
lingering questions from the audience
and then we'll take it off air again
does that sound okay yeah all right that
sounds great
okay let's see
so what do you all think in in the chat
I'm curious how did you like
the podcast
a little behind for me
watching the chat throughout it seemed
that everyone you know everyone was
civil a lot of uh conversation was going
on uh there was a lot of support for
Steven's app as well uh the ce5 app when
we were talking about that a number of
people in the chat use it and vouched
for it
some people are saying that we we
ambushed him and then some people are
saying you didn't ask any hard questions
I mean that It's Tricky yeah we're
always going to get that right like yeah
you went too far you didn't go far
enough when the truth is somewhere in
the middle uh you know
good uh makes people react
well I know I don't think we ambushed
stuff together also our job well at
least I'm not thinking in terms of
Ambush for anyone no I'm not thinking in
terms of let me expose someone I think
in terms of if this is I would like to
understand what this person is saying so
when there are questions if it seems
like an ambush for instance he didn't
like my hand waving which is just my
gesticulation I'm sorry I can't I can't
help that but when I have questions in a
scrupulous manner about some fastidious
physics concept I I don't know what to
I don't know what to do other than ask
and I do that to everyone John vervaki
and mcgilchrist
Avi Loeb exactly and it just gives the
person space to elaborate right yeah you
know I really enjoyed the part where you
and you and Dr we were talking about the
the in-depth physics of things because
it's now often that someone like Dr Lee
will come up against someone who has the
actual knowledge to kind of dive into it
and kind of go wait what do you mean by
scale hour what do you mean by you know
Vector in this sense like it's not quite
the right word you know yes yeah or or
or well I want to ask about time travel
because as soon as he says that
so-and-so travels faster than time then
it implies yes time travel also in my
mind just so you know I'm wondering what
I'm predicting what he's going to say
which is that while you're thinking of
it in the standard model and you have to
think far outside the model well I I
don't I don't know what to say about
that because just like how he has a
checklist for a heart attack I have a
checklist too and every person has a
checklist well yeah it doesn't mean that
you discount the the extraordinary
and does mean that some will slip
through and be incorrectly categorized
so that's also true
okay all right that's pretty cool thank
you all thank you all for coming out
again
Dan is from that UFO podcast I'm from
theories of everything and if you'd like
to support theories of everything visit
theoriesofeverything.org there's no
reason there's no sorry there's no
there's no downside if you don't it's
just if you want to support if you feel
like you can and either way thank you
for coming out
the podcast is finished and what remains
now is just a few minutes of the live
chat prior to Steven coming on where me
and Dan zetterstrom interact with the
audience as we await Greer with baited
breath uh so I can see that Joseph has
already asked is that him off that UFO
podcast uh yeah yes yes it is hi this is
Dan from that UFO podcast Dan is joining
me he will be moderating the live chat
he's making sure that my audio Steven's
audio his own audio works and as well as
the as well as watching the flow and
interjecting with questions here and
there too
so it's like a collaborative effort and
there's
going to be a link once this is posted
in the edited version the final version
that will go online
to that UFO podcast as well as Steven
Greer's links in the description too how
are you feeling about this code are you
nervous like not any more nervous than
any other interview I'm just a regular
amount of apprehension
how about yourself yeah about the same
you know it lets us know that our brains
are working properly if we're a little
bit nervous at this point right it's
like going over the dip on a roller
coaster you know it's coming you're
prepared you accept it but it's
nerve-wracking anyway you're everything
okay with you Dan
yeah everything's great uh this end um
I'm excited I think we we have some
really great questions for for Dr Greer
and I think people are going to be
pleased uh you know provided that we get
to a lot of them anyway uh thank you to
everyone that sent them in we had far
too many um but we can never really have
too many as well so yeah thank you um
and they were all excellent and a note
on that in the future when you're
sending in questions for a guest please
ensure that they're merely questions for
the guest don't type something like
Kurt can you ask him about so-and-so
because firstly that's worded to me like
Kurt can you ask him and I just want to
read it I'm not going to say it to
Stephen Kurt can you ask him about sanso
and also it asks it makes me have to
come up with a question like word it so
that it's verbatim so that I can read it
and then also another tip is to try to
make them as short as possible
think about can it fit in a tweet that's
great because the longer they are my
eyes gloss over and there's so much
background information and there's a
backstory and then there's like a
preface and then an editor's note to the
second edition and I have to edit all
that in my head real time sometimes so
try not to have an intemperate amount of
an exortium please just get straight to
the question
yeah be concise and efficient with the
time I think uh people don't quite
realize how much you have to remember to
do as well as talking to your guest
right so uh yeah this is juggling and
I'm here to help today and we've got a
disclosure team and tupacabra and a
couple of others moderating the live
chat uh thank you to those guys
but yeah there's still a lot to juggle
so another note is you're allowed to ask
tough questions like there's nothing
wrong with tough questions just not
impolitely questions that have embedded
in them assumptions
and well every question has an
assumption but an ODS assumption just be
polite and it's not the same as being
biddable but be polite I I like the the
the Walt Whitman quote of be curious not
judgmental
yeah you know we we want
answers not reactions they're very
different things and people are going to
be more satisfied if we actually have Dr
Greer answer a lot of questions and fill
a lot of the information gaps that we
have rather than you know just an
argument happening on screen which just
isn't isn't the way I agree who um who
has been your favorite UFO guest so far
Kurt
um
you're not allowed to see me I don't
count this isn't guessing let's see
so for Diana I like talking about
philosophy and for Sal I like talking
about physics and math
and okay so for the audience again some
notes Sal is coming up again with Stefan
Alexander as a Theo location that
already occurred I just have to edit it
like put it together and sync the audio
and so on
Tim Maudlin is out so Tim modeling is a
philosopher of physics and if you're
interested in interpretations of quantum
mechanics then
do watch that episode that's out I'll
put it in the description right now you
can search for Tim maudlin
theories of everything or just search
theories of everything is the latest
video
um
Yuri Geller has confirmed to come on to
the podcast however I don't know enough
of his background yet to see if it's a
good fit I was just inquiring hey would
you be willing to come on and I'm not
sure if I have enough material to talk
with him about so let me know what you
all think Kevin knuth will also be
coming on soon
well Kevin's like I love Kevin I asked
him like Hey did you want to come on
like here's the time frame and here's a
couple topics we can talk about he sends
me in like essays upon essays oh and
here's what my current thinking is on
this subject and and here's what we
could talk about and I want to talk
about so and so but I don't have my
thoughts formulated but here they are in
case you want to ask me other questions
I love Kevin
yeah he really runs head first into
everything and he he has his ideas but
the more I find that people in The Wider
World they confuse ideas and the term
hypothesis
um because the hypothesis is testable
right it's not just speculation whereas
Kevin will have hypotheses that he can
go and test and you know he's doing the
work for it so I I love watching
interviews with him yeah as someone here
they they just asked about Dan have you
ever heard of the Hast darling phenomena
have you heard about the hairstyle and
lights go
I want to know what you think yeah I
mean it's really intriguing basically a
bunch of scientists did a study on
things that they thought were UFOs they
kind of had to change the language that
they're using for it so we had terms
like Earth flight so you know plasma
balls or lightning that kind of stuff
talked about but there was a lot of high
strangeness present in the area and it
was almost a skinwalker-esque place for
a little while and now there's a 24 7
monitoring station set up uh that
doesn't have the highest Tech stuff but
it's the kind of place that I wish
Brandon fugled the guy refunding the
skinwalker investigations would invest
in so they could get some better
equipment there like I say the the
activity seems to have gone down a
little bit uh which is strange because
you'd think if it was sorry go on Cut
Steve has entered the waiting room